7:00 AM, Tijuana, Mexico, at a little plaza just outside the border crossing into the United States. About 250 people, lots with backpacks and suitcases, lots with kids, crowd around a woman who holds an oversized notebook in her arms. That's what I've come to see. The notebook.
上午7点，墨西哥蒂华纳，美国边境检查站外的一个小广场上。大约250人，许多人背着背包、拖着行李箱，还有很多孩子，他们围住了一名怀抱超大笔记本的女子。我就是为了一睹这一幕而来，那个笔记本。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Anybody else have 532?
还有谁是532号吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Anybody got 533?
有人拿到533号吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
534? The notebook is a list of names, each neatly written in ballpoint pen. If she calls you, then you get to enter the official port of entry. It's just over the fence. Each number has 10 names under it.
534号？这个笔记本是一份名单，每一个名字都用圆珠笔工整地写在上面。如果她叫到你的名字，你就能进入官方入境口岸。就在围栏那边。每个号码下有10个名字。
OK. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
好的。[讲西班牙语]
You have to get in the book. If you just walk up to the port of entry and say you want asylum in the United States, you're running for your life, they'll tell you to get out. You have to go outside. Get a number. Wait your turn. A couple of people told us this happened to them.
你必须得记在那个本子上。如果你只是径直走到入境口岸，说你想在美国寻求庇护，说你在逃避生命危险，他们会叫你离开。你必须去外面，拿个号码，等待轮到你。有几个人告诉我们，他们就是这样被对待的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
She starts to call out all the names under the number 535. I've edited out the last names here because so many people were nervous about being identified by cartels and gangs when we talked to them.
她开始点535号下的名字。我在这里编辑掉了姓氏，因为当我们和他们交谈时，许多人担心被贩毒集团和帮派认出来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH] Alexa? Alexa? Alberto?
[讲西班牙语] Alexa？Alexa？Alberto？
She's standing outside the busiest border crossing in the Western hemisphere, a complex of buildings so sprawling that I never figured out exactly where they started and ended. It's run by a federal agency with 60,000 employees. This woman is not one of them. She's seeking asylum herself, here with her son.
她站在西半球最繁忙的边境口岸外，那一带建筑群非常庞大，我始终没搞清它们从哪开始、在哪结束。这由一个拥有6万名员工的联邦机构管理。这名女子并不是其中一员。她自己也是寻求庇护者，带着儿子在这里。
She said her husband was killed by gangs back in El Salvador. Then in July, they threatened to do it to her 10-year-old son, too, if she didn't pay up. So she said she quit her job and abandoned her house and came here. That's who we have pulling people from the crowd and lining them up to enter the United States. That's our system for doing it these days.
她说她的丈夫在萨尔瓦多被帮派杀害了。然后在7月份，他们威胁说，如果她不交钱，也要对她10岁的儿子下毒手。所以她说她辞了职，弃了房，来到这里。这就是我们现在安排在人群中整理队伍进入美国的人。这就是我们目前处理这件事的体系。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Calm down. Calm down, she says. Now, in theory, this job shouldn't fall to a random person who's not even a US citizen. Under US law and international treaties, the moment anybody seeking asylum presents him or herself to a border patrol officer, that officer has an obligation to process them, right then.
冷静点。冷静点，她说。按理说，这项工作本不该落在一个连美国公民都不是的普通人身上。根据美国法律和国际条约，任何寻求庇护者向边境巡逻人员出示身份的瞬间，该人员就有义务当场处理他们的申请，对吧？
So in theory, all the people standing in this plaza should be able to march up to the huge border station and get processed immediately. No wait, no notebook with numbers. But under President Trump, the government's saying it doesn't have the capacity to process all the people showing up at our southern border. So people stand outside our border, waiting. Not just here, but at official ports of entry all across the southwest.
所以理论上，站在这个广场上的所有人本应能直接走向庞大的边境站并立即得到处理。不用等待，也不需要那个写着号码的笔记本。但在特朗普总统治下，政府称其没有能力处理出现在南部边境的所有人。所以人们只能站在边境之外等待。不仅是在这里，在整个西南部的官方入境口岸都是如此。
Over the last six months, Customs and Border Protection officers have been stopping asylum seekers from even walking up to federal facilities at the border. This has been filmed by crews from CBS, NBC, Fox, and many others. They stop people in the middle of bridges that cross from Mexico into the United States at El Paso and Brownsville, and turn them away before they can even get to the official ports of entry on the other side to apply for asylum.
过去六个月里，海关及边境保护局的官员一直在阻止寻求庇护者走到边境的联邦设施前。哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）、美国全国广播公司（NBC）、福克斯（Fox）等多家媒体的摄制组都拍下了这一幕。他们在埃尔帕索和布朗斯维尔从墨西哥进入美国的桥梁中间拦住人们，在他们到达另一边的官方入境口岸申请庇护之前就把他们赶走。
Customs and Border Protection says the people are allowed in once space becomes available. They expect this will be temporary, and I quote, "No one is being denied the opportunity to make a claim of credible fear or seek asylum." The lawyers for the immigrants point out that, in the past, these facilities have not had a problem processing the number of people who show up today. So people are kept waiting outside to fend for themselves.
海关及边境保护局称，一旦有空间，人们就会被允许进入。他们预计这只是暂时的，我引用原话：“没有人被拒绝提供陈述受迫害恐惧或寻求庇护的机会。”移民律师指出，过去这些设施处理今天出现的这些人数量时并没有问题。所以人们只能在外面等待，自生自灭。
Here in Tijuana, it's so many people that they wait for weeks. So to keep things orderly, they have this notebook. And because it raises legal issues under asylum law for either the Mexican or American governments to keep a list like this, it's managed by an asylum seeker.
在蒂华纳，人数太多，他们得等上几周。为了保持秩序，他们才有了这个笔记本。而且由于这类名单在墨西哥或美国政府手中保存会引发庇护法方面的法律问题，它是由一名寻求庇护者管理的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
The woman with the notebook is named Karen. She says that when she first arrived here from El Salvador, she put her name in the notebook-- her number is 598-- started paying for a cheap room nearby, and volunteered with Mexican officials to help clean the plaza, or whatever, just to be useful. And then at some point, the Jamaican refugee who'd been managing the notebook got his number called and passed the notebook to her.
拿笔记本的女子叫卡伦。她说当她刚从萨尔瓦多抵达这里时，她把名字写进了本子——她的号码是598——开始在附近付钱租了一个便宜的房间，并自愿协助墨西哥官员清理广场什么的，总之是为了能做点有用的事。后来，之前负责管理笔记本的那位牙买加难民拿到了他的号码，就把笔记本传给了她。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
You really could not pick anybody better for this job. Karen managed people in her old job in the Salvadoran Ministry of Health, and says she was also a leader at her church. And she's good at managing people. When she's not shouting names, she calls everybody "preciosa," precious.
你真的找不到比她更适合这份工作的人了。卡伦在萨尔瓦多卫生部工作时曾负责管理人员，她说她还是她所在教会的领袖。她很擅长管理人们。当她不喊名字时，她管每个人叫“preciosa”，意为“宝贝”。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
And goes about the daily task of disappointing people whose numbers aren't picked with as much kindness as anybody could possibly muster.
她每天都在尽可能温柔地去应对那些号码没被叫到的人，安慰他们。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
I'm going to ask you all a favor, she's saying, but she doesn't say right away what it is. Dozens of tired people look at her.
我请求大家帮个忙，她说，但她没有立刻说是什么忙。几十个疲惫的人看着她。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
I want us all to be happy for those who are going in.
我希望我们都能为那些能够进入的人感到高兴。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Yeah?
是吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH] OK?
[讲西班牙语] 好吗？
Because just like you, I'm waiting for my number, OK?
因为就像你们一样，我也在等我的号码，好吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
I know the effort to be here has been hard for everybody. I know this is really difficult. I understand because I'm living it, too. I'm also paying rent. I'm also spending money on food. But I want to appeal to your conscience, OK?
我知道来到这里对每个人来说都不容易。我知道这真的很难。我理解，因为我也在经历这一切。我也在交房租。我也在花钱买食物。但我想要唤起你们的良知，好吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
And here finally, she gets to the favor. She explains there's a pregnant woman she wants to jump to the front of the line, and she wants everybody be OK with that and feel good about it. Nobody seems too happy with this, but nobody complains, either.
最后，她终于说出了这个请求。她解释说有一位孕妇，她想让对方排到队伍最前面，她希望大家都能同意并对此感到欣慰。没人看起来很高兴，但也没有人抱怨。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
The person who brought me to see this is an LA Times reporter who first wrote about the existence of the notebook, Cindy Carcamo. Although the notebook is supposedly the system that asylum seekers are running for each other to make their wait more orderly, Cindy says they probably didn't create the notebook. In fact, most everything about the notebook is controlled by a Mexican government agency called Grupos Beta.
带我来看这个场景的是《洛杉矶时报》记者辛迪·卡卡莫，她是最先写到这个笔记本存在的人。虽然笔记本被认为是寻求庇护者为彼此制定的让等待更有序的系统，但辛迪说这个笔记本很可能不是他们自己创建的。事实上，关于笔记本的一切几乎都由一个叫“贝塔小组”（Grupos Beta）的墨西哥政府机构控制。
Grupos Beta takes the notebook each night and stores it in a safe. And a Grupos Beta official explained to Cindy and me that every morning, they talk to somebody from US Customs and Border Protection.
贝塔小组每天晚上都会拿走笔记本并存放在保险箱里。一位贝塔小组的官员向我和辛迪解释说，他们每天早上都会与美国海关及边境保护局的人沟通。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]? Or no.
[讲西班牙语]？还是不。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
They just meet, talking. And then he says we're taking this many people in today, and that's how it works. Every day in the morning, US Customs and Border Protection gives a number to Mexican officials, and then the Mexican officials give that number to the notebook keeper and she calls that many names.
他们只是见面沟通。然后他说今天我们要收多少人，事情就是这样运作的。每天早上，美国海关及边境保护局给墨西哥官员一个数字，然后墨西哥官员把这个数字给笔记本管理员，她就叫多少个名字。
On this particular day, only 20 people were allowed to enter the port of entry. One day earlier in the week, it was zero. On any given day, with over 1,000 names uncalled in the notebook, it's 20, or 30, or 40. 50's the most anybody had seen.
在这一天，只有20人被允许进入入境口岸。本周早些时候有一天是零。在任何一天，笔记本上有超过1000个名字没被叫到，但也只能进20、30或40人。50人是任何人见过的最多人数。
Cindy and I talked to lots of people who were waiting, and they were pretty much exactly who you'd expect. Many of them said they were escaping violence in Mexico or Central America. Some seemed truly terrified, even here in the plaza. One woman said that yesterday, her son thought that he'd spotted one of the men who was after them at the shelter they were staying at, so they fled to a hotel.
我和辛迪与许多等待的人聊过，他们基本就是你所预期的那样。许多人说他们正在逃离墨西哥或中美洲的暴力。有些人看起来真的很恐惧，即使是在广场上。一位妇女说，昨天，她的儿子在他们寄宿的收容所似乎发现了追杀他们的人中的一个，所以他们逃到了一家旅馆。
But we also met a 29-year-old mom named Lara, from a tiny Mexican town called Jalapa in Guerrero, who is here because her cousin in California keeps telling her that her kids would have a better life in the United States. So she sold off everything and brought the five of them here-- really nice kids, by the way-- hoping for political asylum.
但我们也遇到了一位29岁的妈妈，叫拉拉，来自格雷罗州一个叫哈拉帕的小镇，她在这里是因为她在加州的堂姐一直告诉她，她的孩子在美国会有更好的生活。所以她卖掉了一切，把五个孩子带到了这里——顺便说一下，孩子们真的很可爱——希望能获得政治庇护。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
No.
没有。
No. No violence, she said. It's not about violence.
没有。没有暴力，她说。这不是关于暴力的问题。
If she's not fleeing violence, she doesn't really have much chance of getting asylum in the United States. It was weird to talk to somebody and know that she probably would not get what she had pinned all her hopes on and traveled 1,500 miles for, and that she and her kids were probably going to wait for weeks and then get turned back. I never had the experience of knowing so clearly someone's future that they do not know. It was hard to keep looking her in the eye.
如果她不是在逃离暴力，她在申请美国庇护方面其实没什么机会。和一个可能不会得到她倾注所有希望、跋涉1500英里想要的东西的人交谈，知道她和她的孩子们很可能要等上几周然后被遣返，这感觉很奇怪。我从未如此清晰地预见到别人的未来，而他们自己却不知道。看着她的眼睛很难受。
You know, everything was in Spanish, right? So I don't understand Spanish. I didn't get anything. So I want to know what's happening.
你知道，一切都是西班牙语，对吧？我不懂西班牙语。我什么也没听懂。所以我很想知道发生了什么。
Give me a moment.
给我一点时间。
Yesterday you told me "manana." Today again, "manana."
昨天你告诉我“明天”。今天又是“明天”。
OK.
好。
When Karen finished rounding up her 20 people for the day, this guy from Cameroon, named Ransom, approached her. Karen's English doesn't go much past "give me a moment," and his Spanish doesn't go much past "manana." So Karen dragged in Cindy, the LA Times reporter, to translate.
当卡伦忙完一天20人的名额后，这个叫兰索姆的喀麦隆人走近了她。卡伦的英语水平超不过“给我一点时间”，而他的西班牙语水平超不过“明天”。于是卡伦拉上《洛杉矶时报》记者辛迪来翻译。
But can you ask her how many people will be waiting tomorrow?
但你能问问她明天会有多少人排队吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
When they're done, Ransom told me and Cindy that he left Cameroon with 16 other people three months before. They flew to Ecuador, which is a path that lots of people take because visas are easy to get there. Then they walked through the jungle, north through Central America, sleeping in the bush, till they got here three weeks ago.
交谈结束后，兰索姆告诉我和辛迪，他三个月前和另外16个人离开了喀麦隆。他们飞往厄瓜多尔，那是许多人选择的路径，因为那里的签证很容易拿到。然后他们穿过丛林，一路向北穿过中美洲，睡在灌木丛里，直到三周前到达这里。
It's been a tough journey. It's really been tough. It's been a long way. The money is finished. Like, I don't have a way to stay. That's the problem. That's why I'm frustrated. That's the problem.
这是一段艰难的旅程。真的很艰难。路途遥远。钱花光了。比如，我没有办法留下来。这就是问题所在。这就是为什么我感到沮丧。这就是问题。
Where are you staying?
你住在哪里？
We just live nearby. We just-- you wouldn't understand. It's quite tough. We're like 40 people in one room. One small room. It's just-- I don't know how something like that--
我们就住在附近。我们只是——你不会明白的。这相当艰难。我们大概40个人挤在一个房间里。一个小房间。这只是——我不知道那种情况怎么会——
How much do you pay for that?
你每月付多少钱？
We pay like $50 a month.
我们一个月付大约50美元。
And he's going to be here so long that he has to pay a second month. He says they were robbed along the way in the jungle. So when he arrived in Tijuana three weeks ago, he only had $80. With so little money, how is he surviving?
他在这里呆的时间太长了，以至于必须付第二个月的房租。他说他们在丛林中被抢劫了。所以当他三周前到达蒂华纳时，他只有80美元。只有这么点钱，他是怎么活下来的？
Well, water in the absence of food. I drink water.
嗯，在没有食物的情况下喝水。我喝水。
The situation he's fleeing should make him a good candidate for asylum in the United States. The government of Cameroon has been killing the English-speaking minority in the country and burning their homes, trying to suppress an armed uprising.
他逃离的处境本应让他成为美国庇护的理想候选人。喀麦隆政府一直在杀害国内讲英语的少数群体并烧毁他们的房屋，试图镇压武装起义。
But it's a hard moment to try to enter our country. The Trump administration is doing all kinds of things to be stricter with potential immigrants. And as you'll hear this hour, some of them are keeping desperate people waiting outside the border for weeks. Even if you understand that we're trying to be stricter with who's coming into the country, it can be hard to understand why we're doing it like this.
但现在是尝试进入我们国家的艰难时刻。特朗普政府正在采取各种措施对潜在移民更加严厉。正如你在这个小时里听到的，其中一些措施让绝望的人在边境之外等待数周。即使你理解我们试图对进入该国的人员实施更严格的限制，也很难理解我们为什么要以这种方式行事。
Today on our program, I think at this point, most of us have heard about a few of the things that the President and his appointees have done to try to get control of the border. We've heard about the family separations, we've heard about the travel ban. But in fact, it's a wide-ranging, coordinated effort across many agencies. All kinds of things that have not gotten a lot of attention.
今天在我们的节目中，我想此时大多数人都已经听说过总统及其任命的官员为试图控制边境所采取的一些措施。我们听说了家庭分离，听说了旅行禁令。但实际上，这是一项跨越多个机构的广泛、协调的努力。各种各样没有得到太多关注的事情。
What's interesting is that so much of their effort, lots of the things that they're doing, are not cracking down on people breaking the law or sneaking across the border, not targeting criminals or bad hombres. Many of the efforts are targeted at the people who are trying their best to play by the rules and do what we ask of foreigners who want to come here. People trying to obey our laws, like asylum seekers showing up at our door saying, I'm in danger at home. Your laws allow me to apply for haven.
有趣的是，他们的许多努力、他们正在做的很多事情，并不是打击违法或潜入边境的人，也不是针对罪犯或坏分子。许多努力针对的是那些竭尽全力遵守规则、按照我们要求向那些想要来这里的人行事的人。那些试图遵守我们法律的人，比如出现在我们门口说“我在家乡处于危险中，你们的法律允许我申请避难”的寻求庇护者。
Today we take you on a tour of the many, many things that are all happening, the ways that we're shutting our doors to outsiders. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天我们将带你参观正在发生的所有事情，以及我们拒之门外的方式。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请留下。
Act One, All Together Now. So to enter the United States from the south, you can go to the official border station, the port of entry, and do it legally, like the people who you heard trying to do it in that plaza in Tijuana. Well, you might get to that plaza, see the line, see the wait, and pause, or maybe try to go to the border station in Brownsville or El Paso. Again, you might pause and decide to take your kids, and take your chances, and head out to cross the border illegally.
第一幕，大家一起。所以，要从南部进入美国，你可以去官方边境站，也就是入境口岸，合法进入，就像你在蒂华纳广场听到的那些人试图做的那样。嗯，你可能会到达那个广场，看到排队，看到等待，然后停下来，或者可能尝试去布朗斯维尔或埃尔帕索的边境站。同样，你可能会犹豫，决定带上孩子，碰碰运气，然后非法跨越边境。
I was talking to a Customs and Border Protection officer, a spokesman for the union, Chris Cabrera. He patrols the area around the Rio Grande and he says that he picks up people like this all the time. They tell him they tried the port of entry.
我当时正在和一名海关及边境保护局官员、工会发言人克里斯·卡布雷拉交谈。他在里奥格兰德河周边巡逻，他说他一直在抓捕这样的人。他们告诉他，他们尝试过入境口岸。
The line was too long. They didn't want to wait that long. And that's why a lot of them choose to come through the river, because they don't want to wait.
队伍太长了。他们不想等那么久。这就是为什么他们中的很多人选择穿过河流，因为他们不想等。
Once he apprehends them, there's something new now that they go through under this administration. A new thing that's happening on the border. People caught crossing into the country illegally are being rounded up and sent to federal criminal court in mass hearings with dozens of people getting sentenced at the same time. The government has done these hearings in the past, but never on the scale that's happening now.
一旦他抓获他们，现在他们在这个政府下经历了一些新的东西。边境上发生的一件新事。被抓到非法进入该国的人正在被聚集起来，送往联邦刑事法庭进行大规模听证会，几十人同时被判刑。政府过去也做过这种听证会，但规模从未达到现在的程度。
As of April, they're doing them in every district along the border, sometimes twice a day, with tens of thousands of people convicted. They're prosecuting a crime that didn't used to be treated like a crime. Before this, if you cross the border illegally, you'd most likely just get put into immigration proceedings and probably deported. Now, you go through criminal court first, even if you came here to ask for asylum.
截至4月，他们在边境沿线的所有地区都在进行这种听证，有时一天两次，有数万人被定罪。他们正在起诉一种过去不被视为犯罪的行为。在此之前，如果你非法越境，你最有可能只是进入移民程序并可能被驱逐出境。现在，你首先要经历刑事法庭，即使你来到这里是为了申请庇护。
This is happening under the administration's Zero Tolerance Policy. You probably heard about the part of that policy that separated children from their parents. That part has officially ended. But this move to prosecute border crossings as criminal offenses, this was actually the main point of the Zero Tolerance Policy.
这是在政府的“零容忍政策”下发生的。你可能听说过该政策中将儿童与父母分离的那部分。那部分已经正式结束。但这一将非法越境作为刑事犯罪起诉的举动，实际上才是“零容忍政策”的重点。
Reporter Julia Preston went to McAllen, Texas, to one of the courts that's had the highest number of prosecutions since this all started to see what this looks like in practice. And what she discovered is what's happening now is just the first step towards much bigger things that are in the works. Here's Julia.
记者朱莉娅·普雷斯顿去了德克萨斯州的麦卡伦，前往自这一切开始以来起诉案件数量最高的法院之一，看看这在实践中是什么样子。她发现，现在正在发生的事情只是正在酝酿的更大事情的第一步。以下是朱莉娅的报道。
Picture a federal courtroom. The defendants sit with their lawyers at one table, the prosecutors on the other side, the judge up front. The McAllen courtroom was a stunningly different site. Five rows of wooden benches, usually meant for visitors, were packed with defendants, squeezed in shoulder to shoulder. 74 of them.
想象一下联邦法庭。被告和他们的律师坐在一张桌子旁，检察官在另一侧，法官坐在前面。麦卡伦法庭是一个截然不同的场景。五排通常供访客使用的木制长椅上挤满了被告，肩膀挨着肩膀。总共74人。
The defendants were dressed in tattered t-shirts and jeans, not prison uniforms. Some of the men had trouble keeping their pants up when they stood because their belts were taken away when they were detained. They'd been caught by the Border Patrol after they crossed the Rio Grande River. Most of them just one or two days before.
被告穿着破旧的T恤和牛仔裤，而不是囚服。有些男人站立时不得不提着裤子，因为他们的腰带在被拘留时被没收了。他们在越过里奥格兰德河后被边境巡逻队抓获。他们中的大多数人就在一两天前被抓。
Ladies and gentlemen, let me ask you please to stand and raise your right hand. Take an oath before the court this morning for these proceedings.
女士们、先生们，请允许我请你们站起来并举起右手。在今天早上的这些诉讼程序前进行宣誓。
That's the sound of 74 people standing up to be sworn in when they're shackled at the ankles and chained around the waist. They all had one hand that was cuffed tightly to the waist chain and just one hand free.
那是74人站起来宣誓的声音，他们的脚踝戴着脚镣，腰间缠着铁链。他们每个人都有一只手紧紧地铐在腰链上，只有一只手是自由的。
In another hearing I went to, there were 87 defendants. In that one, the marshals had to put some of them in the jury box. The defendants would all be out of there-- charged, convicted, and sentenced-- in just over two hours. It was mass justice at head-spinning speed.
在我去的另一场听证会上，有87名被告。在那场听证会上，法警不得不把其中一些人安排在陪审团席上。这些被告——被起诉、定罪、判刑——将在两个多小时内全部结束离开。这是以令人目眩的速度进行的大规模司法审判。
The magistrate judge presiding over this hearing, Scott Hacker, didn't sit in his usual place on the high bench. Instead, he spent the whole hearing on his feet, right in front of the migrants, so he could see each one of them. The migrants were wearing wireless headphones to hear the Spanish interpreter. Judge Hacker took a few minutes to make sure everyone's headphone was working.
主持这场听证会的治安法官斯科特·哈克没有坐在他平时高高的法官席上。相反，他在整个听证期间都站着，就在移民们面前，这样他就能看清每一个人。移民们戴着无线耳机收听西班牙语翻译。哈克法官花了几分钟确保每个人的耳机都能正常工作。
Sir, can you hear? The gentlemen next to you. Can you hear?
先生，你能听见吗？你旁边的先生。你能听见吗？
The defendants awkwardly adjusted their headphones with their one free hand. Throughout the hearing, the security guards ran around as tech support, resetting the headphones or swapping them out for fresh ones. Judge Hacker ran the hearing like a professor, explaining things in plain language and raising an index finger in the air in big gestures to punctuate his points. He addressed the migrants as sir and ma'am, and ladies and gentlemen.
被告们用他们唯一自由的手笨拙地调整着耳机。在整个听证过程中，保安人员像技术支持一样跑来跑去，重置耳机或换上新的。哈克法官像教授一样主持听证会，用通俗易懂的语言解释事情，并用食指在空中比划大动作来强调他的重点。他称呼移民们为“先生”和“女士”，以及“女士们、先生们”。
This is your day in court. It's important that you hear and understand everything that I explain to you.
这是你们在法庭上的日子。你们听到并理解我解释的一切非常重要。
I'll admit, I was surprised. I was expecting some kind of rodeo justice. People herded through with no idea what was happening to them. But it wasn't that. The judge, the public defenders, even the prosecutors seemed to be working hard to ensure that all 74 defendants got some kind of basic due process. Every time the judge explained something, he would go around pointing to each defendant, one by one, getting them to confirm that they understood.
我承认，我感到惊讶。我原本预想的是某种“牛仔正义”。人们被成群地赶过去，根本不知道在他们身上发生了什么。但事实并非如此。法官、公设辩护律师，甚至检察官似乎都在努力确保所有74名被告都能获得某种基本的正当程序。法官每次解释一些事情，他都会绕场一周，一个个指着每位被告，让他们确认他们理解了。
Then I'll start with the person on the front row. [INAUDIBLE]. He'll answer yes or no, then I'll point to Miss [INAUDIBLE]. She'll answer. Then I'll point to Miss Perez, she'll answer.
那么我从第一排的那个人开始。[听不清]。他会回答是或否，然后我指向[听不清]女士。她会回答。然后我指向佩雷斯女士，她会回答。
When I'm finished with the first row, I'll start with the gentleman on the second row. The third row, the fourth row, and continue until I get everyone. Have you understood the instructions? Yes or no, sir. Next.
当我结束第一排后，我将从第二排的绅士开始。第三排，第四排，并继续直到每个人都结束。你们理解指令了吗？是或否，先生。下一位。
Yes.
是。
Si.
是的（西班牙语）。
Yes.
是。
Si.
是的（西班牙语）。
Yes.
是。
Si.
是的（西班牙语）。
Yes.
是。
Si.
是的（西班牙语）。
Yes.
是。
Si.
是的（西班牙语）。
Yes.
是。
Si.
是的（西班牙语）。
Yes.
是。
Si.
是的（西班牙语）。
Yes.
是。
Si.
是的（西班牙语）。
74 yeses. Over the course of the hearing, he would go around to every person this way a total of 16 times. Judge Hacker explained the crime they were accused of, illegal entry. It's a federal offense, but the first time around it's a minor one. A misdemeanor.
74个“是”。在整个听证过程中，他总共以这种方式绕场询问了每个人16次。哈克法官解释了他们被控的罪名：非法入境。这是一项联邦罪名，但初犯只是一项轻罪。
Do each of you understand this charge of illegal entry? Please answer yes or no, starting with you, sir.
你们每个人都理解这项非法入境的指控吗？请回答是或否，从你开始，先生。
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
Si, senor. Yes, yes, yes 74 times. A judge I observed in another hearing had a different method. For some questions, he had all the defendants answer in unison, which sounded like this.
是的，先生。是，是，是，74次。我在另一场听证会上观察到的一位法官有不同的方法。对于某些问题，他让所有被告齐声回答，听起来是这样的。
Do each of you understand your right to an attorney?
你们每个人都了解你们获得律师的权利吗？
Si.
是的（西班牙语）。
Yes.
是。
The sheer amount of paperwork that went into that hearing was immense. The documents for each person had to have the right name with correct spelling, the right country they were from, the right place and date where they were apprehended. The right details about how they crossed the river, whether they were on a raft, or a boat, or they swam, or they waded.
听证会所涉及的文书工作量极其巨大。每个人的文件都必须有正确的拼写名字、正确的来源国、他们被抓获的正确地点和日期。关于他们如何过河的正确细节，无论是乘坐木筏、船只、游泳还是涉水。
I found out later that Customs and Border Protection has an office nearby where agents, and lawyers, and paralegals work through the night to get all those piles of documents ready by dawn on the morning of the hearing. The Border Patrol wasn't happy about this use of their agents. Officials told me they would much rather have the agents out on the front line patrolling the border.
我后来发现，海关及边境保护局在附近有一个办公室，代理人、律师和律师助理彻夜工作，以便在听证会当天的黎明前准备好所有成堆的文件。边境巡逻队对动用他们的代理人做这些事并不高兴。官员们告诉我，他们更希望让代理人在前线巡逻边境。
The judge carefully explained their right to a trial and the possible consequences of pleading guilty-- fines, jail time, deportation. They did have the option of pleading not guilty and going to trial, but they still wouldn't stand a chance of winning because, for most of them, the border patrol had caught them near the Rio Grande. They had admitted when and where they crossed the river, so there really wasn't much room for argument. They'd been caught in the act.
法官仔细解释了他们接受审判的权利以及认罪的可能后果——罚款、监禁、驱逐出境。他们确实可以选择不认罪并接受审判，但他们仍然没有获胜的机会，因为对他们大多数人来说，边境巡逻队是在里奥格兰德河附近抓到他们的。他们承认了过河的时间和地点，所以真的没有多少辩论余地。他们被当场抓获。
The federal public defenders, all 18 of them in the McAllen office, had come to the courtroom in the hours before the hearing to meet with each defendant and basically prepare them to plead guilty. Most of those meetings lasted just a few minutes, then everyone declared their plea.
麦卡伦办公室的18名联邦公设辩护律师在听证会前几小时来到法庭，与每位被告见面，基本上准备让他们认罪。大多数会议只持续了几分钟，然后每个人都宣布了他们的抗辩。
Mr. Santos, they're saying your illegal entry occurred on the 19th of this month. How do you plead? Guilty or not guilty.
桑托斯先生，他们说你是在本月的19日非法入境的。你如何抗辩？认罪还是不认罪。
Guilty.
认罪。
Mr. Morales, they're saying your illegal entry occurred on the 19th of this month.
莫拉莱斯先生，他们说你是在本月的19日非法入境的。
74 guilty pleas. Even when you know it's coming, it's a somber thing to see. A group of people I wondered about during this hearing were the migrants who wanted to seek asylum. Because even with a criminal conviction, they can still apply for asylum, but it wasn't clear the migrants understood that.
74个认罪。即使你知道会发生什么，看到这一幕也是一件令人伤感的事情。我在这次听证会中好奇的一群人是那些想要寻求庇护的移民。因为即使有刑事定罪，他们仍然可以申请庇护，但移民们是否理解这一点并不清楚。
Before sentencing, a man from Nicaragua stood up, worried and apologetic. He told the judge he'd come to the US to apply for political asylum. He'd brought evidence of his persecution.
在判刑前，一名来自尼加拉瓜的男子站起来，担忧并道歉。他告诉法官他来到美国是为了申请政治庇护。他带来了他受迫害的证据。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
If he took a guilty plea, he asked, would he be deported right away and never get a chance at asylum? Judge Hacker thought he would get a chance, but he couldn't say for certain. He's not an immigration judge.
如果他选择认罪，他问道，他会被立即驱逐出境而永远没有机会申请庇护吗？哈克法官认为他会有机会，但他不能确定。他不是移民法官。
The way it works is that, after the hearing, the man will be transferred into detention in the immigration system, a different system, and there, he'll have to insist to the officers that he wants to pursue his asylum claims. A lot of people might not figure that out. For many asylum seekers, going first to criminal court was very confusing.
运作方式是，在听证会结束后，该男子将被转移到移民系统的拘留所中，这是一个不同的系统，在那里，他必须向官员坚持他想要追求他的庇护主张。很多人可能不知道这一点。对于许多寻求庇护者来说，先去刑事法庭非常令人困惑。
Then it was time for the sentences. Often in federal court, this takes days or weeks. But here, the judge didn't skip a beat. The sentences came right away. 10 days, 20 days for a handful of cases. People who had some kind of record-- who'd been convicted of illegal entry before, or had drug or domestic violence convictions, traffic violations-- the longest sentence for that group was 100 days.
然后到了判刑的时候。通常在联邦法院，这需要几天或几周。但在这里，法官毫不拖延。判决立即生效。10天，少数案件20天。那些有某种记录的人——之前曾因非法入境被定罪，或有毒品或家庭暴力定罪、交通违规——这一组最长的刑期是100天。
Everyone else, though-- the vast majority in this courtroom-- had no criminal record in the US and this was their first illegal entry offense. All of those people were given the same sentence, time served. In other words, the time they'd already spent in detention, which, for most of them, was less than two days. Two days. All of this work to deter illegal crossings, and yet most everyone walked out of the court that day with basically no punishment.
然而，其他人——法庭中的绝大多数人——在美国没有犯罪记录，这是他们的初次非法入境犯罪。所有这些人被判处相同的刑期：服刑时间。换句话说，他们已经在拘留所度过的时间，对大多数人来说，不到两天。两天。所有这些阻止非法越境的努力，然而大多数人在那天走出法庭时基本没有受到惩罚。
Leaving the courtroom, I had a lot of questions. When Attorney General Jeff Sessions talks about this new policy of prosecuting everyone who crosses the border illegally, he says its purpose is to deter people from making those crossings. But how is two days of detention any kind of deterrent? It didn't make sense. Especially when you consider the massive amount of resources that go into these hearings.
离开法庭时，我有许多问题。当司法部长杰夫·塞申斯谈到这一起诉所有非法越境者的新政策时，他说其目的是阻止人们进行这些越境行为。但两天的拘留怎么能起到威慑作用？这说不通。尤其是当你考虑到这些听证会投入的大量资源时。
The border patrol agents writing up the charges, the paralegals, the court clerks, the prosecutors checking criminal backgrounds, and figuring out who they should recommend for extra jail time. The Justice Department added eight new prosecutors in southern Texas this summer for these cases. 18 public defenders, the marshals and security guards, getting dozens of shackled people in and out of the courthouse. The buses and vans to get them there.
边境巡逻人员撰写指控、律师助理、法院书记员、检察官检查犯罪背景并决定应该推荐谁加重监禁。司法部今年夏天在德克萨斯州南部增加了八名新检察官负责这些案件。18名公设辩护人，法警和保安人员，把几十个戴着手铐的人送进送出法院。接送他们的公共汽车和货车。
And these misdemeanor cases are sapping away the energy and time of everyone for the other business of the court, which is prosecuting more serious crimes, including narcotics, money laundering, trafficking, and weapons offenses. I really didn't know what to make of it all until I had a conversation with Ryan Patrick.
而这些轻罪案件正在消耗每个人的精力和时间去做法院的其他事务，包括起诉更严重的罪行，包括毒品、洗钱、贩运和武器犯罪。我真的不知道该怎么看这一切，直到我和瑞安·帕特里克进行了谈话。
He's the head prosecutor of the federal district that McAllen is part of, the Southern District of Texas. And he told me something I hadn't heard from the attorney general or President Trump. He told me these misdemeanor prosecutions are just phase one of a larger strategy by the Justice Department.
他是麦卡伦所属联邦地区（德克萨斯南区）的首席检察官。他告诉我一些我没有从司法部长或特朗普总统那里听到的事情。他告诉我，这些轻罪起诉只是司法部更大战略的第一阶段。
So some of the way these cases are handled could very well change as our resources, on our side, change, as well.
所以，随着我们这边的资源变化，这些案件的处理方式很可能会发生改变。
When you say it could very well change, you mean there could be more felony cases?
当你说很可能会改变时，你的意思是可能会有更多的重罪案件？
There could be. Yes, ma'am.
可能会有。是的，女士。
I see. Is that the goal, or is that where you're trying to go with this?
我明白了。这就是目标，或者这就是你们试图达到的方向吗？
As appropriate, and for cases that we can prove, yes, we will file more felony cases.
视情况而定，对于我们可以证明的案件，是的，我们将提起更多的重罪诉讼。
With illegal entry, the first offense is a misdemeanor. But if somebody is caught crossing illegally a second time, they can be prosecuted for a felony and go to prison for up to two years. A felony conviction makes it very difficult for a person ever to get a visa to enter the United States legally, much less get a green card or become a citizen.
对于非法入境，初犯是轻罪。但如果有人再次被抓到非法越境，他们可能会被起诉犯有重罪并入狱长达两年。重罪定罪使一个人几乎不可能获得签证合法进入美国，更不用说获得绿卡或成为公民了。
The government's ramping up to prosecute more people. Border patrol is hiring. So are the US Marshals. In May, 32% of people caught crossing the southwest border were sent to be prosecuted. A month later, it was 46% of them. Administration officials told me the goal is 100%. Literally zero tolerance for illegal crossings.
政府正在加强起诉更多的人。边境巡逻队正在招聘。美国法警也在招聘。5月份，在西南边境被抓获的人中有32%被起诉。一个月后，这一数字上升到46%。政府官员告诉我，目标是100%。对非法越境真正“零容忍”。
This could mean prosecuting something like 200,000 people a year for the misdemeanor offense. Before long, it could mean tens of thousands of newly convicted felons in federal prison. President Trump and the attorney general have long said that people who cross the border illegally are just criminals. Now, every day, more and more of them are becoming exactly that.
这意味着每年可能会起诉大约20万人犯轻罪。不久之后，可能会有数万名新定罪的重罪犯在联邦监狱服刑。特朗普总统和司法部长长期以来一直说非法越境的人只是罪犯。现在，每天都有越来越多的人成为确确实实的罪犯。
Julia Preston. She's a contributing writer to The Marshall Project. You can read a print version of her story on The Marshall Project's website, marshallproject.org.
朱莉娅·普雷斯顿。她是《马歇尔项目》（The Marshall Project）的特约撰稿人。你可以在《马歇尔项目》网站 marshallproject.org 上阅读她故事的印刷版。
Act Two, The Kitchen Sink. So the administration's immigration policy-- this has been widely reported-- is run from the office of White House senior advisor, Stephen Miller. He's 33 years old, brings a detailed knowledge of immigration issues and regulations to the task, has installed like-minded people at the various agencies that deal with immigration.
第二幕，厨房水槽。所以政府的移民政策——这已经被广泛报道——是由白宫高级顾问斯蒂芬·米勒的办公室管理的。他33岁，为这项任务带来了对移民问题和法规的详细了解，并在处理移民问题的各个机构中安插了志同道合的人。
We requested sit-down interviews with him, and with numerous other administration officials throughout the government. They all turned us down. But I'm going to take this act and try to give you a sense of the sweep of the changes that they put into place. The variety, and ingenuity, and comprehensiveness of them. Here we go.
我们请求与他以及政府中其他许多政府官员进行坐谈采访。他们都拒绝了我们。但我将利用这一幕，试图让你了解他们所采取的一系列变化的广度。它们的多样性、独创性和全面性。我们开始吧。
The administration has brought back workplace raids at a level that hasn't been done for years, rounding up hundreds of undocumented people at a time. The State Department and Department of Homeland Security have cracked down on recalcitrant countries. Yes, that is an official designation that we give to some countries. Recalcitrant. These are countries that do not accept deportees that we want to send them.
政府恢复了多年未见规模的职场突袭，一次逮捕数百名无证件人员。国务院和国土安全部打击了“拒绝合作的国家”。是的，这是我们给一些国家的官方名称：拒绝合作。这些国家不接受我们想遣返的被驱逐者。
There were 20 countries like that just after the President took office. His administration has twisted arms, imposed sanctions, and convinced more than half of those countries to take people back, clearing the way for 15,000 more people to be deported. The Department of Homeland Security has set up a de-naturalization task force to go after people who lied on their citizenship applications, and literally strip away their citizenship.
在总统上任后不久，有20个这样的国家。他的政府采取强硬手段，施加制裁，并说服了超过一半的国家带回他们的人，为多遣返1.5万人扫清了道路。国土安全部成立了一个取消入籍工作组，针对在公民身份申请中撒谎的人，并字面意义上剥夺他们的公民身份。
The attorney general has changed the rules so that if you're fleeing gang violence or domestic violence, even if immigration agents believe that your life is in danger, that's not grounds for asylum in the United States. This affects a lot of people. The Attorney General explained it this way--
司法部长修改了规则，因此如果你正在逃离帮派暴力或家庭暴力，即使移民代理人认为你的生命处于危险之中，这也不再是美国庇护的理由。这影响了很多人。司法部长是这样解释的——
Asylum is not generally for those who suffered from a private act of violence or if a gang is in the neighborhood. It's always from members of groups who are persecuted by the state. Asylum was never meant to solve all problems, even serious problems, that people face every day all over the world.
庇护通常不是为了那些遭受私人暴力行为的人，也不是为了社区里有帮派的人。它总是为了那些受到国家迫害的群体成员。庇护从未意味着要解决人们每天在世界各地面临的所有问题，即使是严重的问题。
And then there's a whole set of policies the Trump administration has put into place that affects all of the people who are trying to lawfully enter the United States. Filling out forms, sending in information, waiting their turns. They are all coming under increased scrutiny.
然后，特朗普政府实施了一整套政策，影响所有试图合法进入美国的人。填写表格、提交信息、等待轮到他们。他们都受到了越来越严密的审查。
The forms are much longer. Applicants are called in to be interviewed about things they were never called in for before. And attorneys who help people through this process will tell you that they're getting a ton of what they call RFE's, Requests for Evidence, for perfectly ordinary things that, in the past, would have been routine.
表格长得多。申请人被叫去面试以前从未被叫去面试的事情。帮助人们完成这个过程的律师会告诉你，他们收到了大量他们所说的“补充证据请求”（RFE），针对的是在过去本应是例行公事的普通事情。
Here's an example. Immigration attorney Marisol Perez works at a firm that filed a visa request on behalf of their client, the Archdiocese of San Antonio, which is trying to hire a priest from another country. They were surprised when they got an RFE from the government-- I've seen this-- asking them to prove that, in fact, the archdiocese really exists as a functioning business.
举个例子。移民律师玛丽索尔·佩雷斯在一家公司工作，他们代表他们的客户——圣安东尼奥总教区，该教区试图从另一个国家雇佣一名神父——提交了一份签证请求。当他们收到政府发来的RFE时——我见过这个——要求他们证明圣安东尼奥总教区实际上确实作为一个正常运转的企业存在时，他们感到惊讶。
It was shocking to us. This is the second-largest archdiocese-- Catholic archdiocese-- in the country. Certainly they're in business. Certainly they're flourishing. Certainly they are a legitimate operating business.
我们感到震惊。这是国内第二大天主教总教区。当然他们在营业。当然他们正在蓬勃发展。当然他们是一个合法经营的企业。
Do you think it was just a bureaucratic snafu?
你认为这只是一个官僚主义的失误吗？
If I chalked it up to that, there are lots of bureaucratic snafus.
如果我把它归结为失误，那这里有太多的官僚主义失误了。
It didn't take much work for me to collect some. There was the musician who was told that the two Grammys he won and the three that he was nominated for, but did not win, were not sufficient evidence of his musical talent, and that more proof would be required before he could reside in the United States.
我没费多大劲就收集了一些。有一位音乐家被告知，他获得的两个格莱美奖和提名的三个但未获奖的奖项不足以证明他的音乐天赋，在他能居住在美国之前需要更多的证明。
There was the RFE asking a British citizen to have her British birth certificate translated into English, please. There was the RFE where the government argued that an architect didn't qualify for the visa he wanted because you don't need a specialized degree to be an architect. Even though, of course, you do need a specialized degree. According to one study, in the last quarter of 2017 alone, the percentage of work visas getting RFE's tripled. 3/4 of them got RFE's.
有一个RFE要求一名英国公民将她的英国出生证明翻译成英文，请。有一个RFE中政府辩称一名建筑师没有资格获得他想要的签证，因为做建筑师不需要专业学位。尽管当然，你是需要专业学位的。根据一项研究，仅在2017年第四季度，获得RFE的工作签证百分比就增加了两倍。3/4的人收到了RFE。
The most mundane ones are just asking for documents that you've already sent.
最平凡的只是要求你已经发送过的文件。
Jacqueline Watson is an immigration attorney in Austin. She says she's now seeing this in the vast majority of cases she files. RFE's asking for stuff she's already submitted.
杰奎琳·沃森是奥斯汀的一名移民律师。她说她现在在绝大多数案件中都看到了这一点。RFE要求提供她已经提交过的东西。
If it happens in one case, you can say, OK, that was a mistake. If it happens in almost every case you file, there's something wrong.
如果它发生在一个案件中，你可以说，好吧，那是一个错误。如果它发生在你提交的几乎每个案件中，那就有问题了。
She and other immigration attorneys see it as a deliberate strategy to gum up the works, slow the process, discourage people from applying, give out fewer visas. And she said when you get an RFE, it also means you can't get work permits or travel permits that you would otherwise be able to get while applying.
她和其他移民律师将其视为故意拖延工作、放慢流程、劝阻人们申请、减少发放签证的策略。她说当你收到RFE时，这也意味着你无法获得你在申请时本可以获得的工作许可或旅行证件。
A spokesman for the US citizenship and Immigration Services, USCIS emailed me a statement saying that assertions that they are trying to slow the immigration process are, quote, "inaccurate" and, in fact, their reforms are intended to do the opposite. Quote, "reduce incomplete or frivolous filings, thus speeding up the immigration process for many applicants and petitioners, allowing them to receive a decision faster."
美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）的发言人通过电子邮件给我发了一份声明，称关于他们试图放慢移民进程的断言是“不准确的”，事实上，他们的改革旨在做相反的事情。引用：“减少不完整或轻率的申请，从而加快许多申请人和请愿人的移民进程，让他们更快收到决定。”
Attorneys say visas and green cards are now being turned down all the time for reasons that they never saw before. One big one that I was told comes up a lot is applications being rejected because the government thinks that you'll become a burden on the public. And the attorneys I spoke with sounded truly bewildered by the way that they are enforcing this.
律师们表示，现在签证和绿卡因为他们以前从未见过的原因一直被拒绝。我被告知经常出现的一个大理由是申请被拒绝，因为政府认为你会成为公众的负担。而我采访的律师对他们执行此项政策的方式感到真正困惑。
For example, Marisol Perez has a client who's 11 years old, born in Mexico. His mom married an American and wanted to bring him to the United States, and the green card application had everything the government has asked for in the past. Father made enough money, father was working, showed his tax returns. But the kid was turned down because the government said that he would become a public charge.
例如，玛丽索尔·佩雷斯有一位11岁的客户，出生在墨西哥。他的妈妈嫁给了一个美国人，想把他带到美国，绿卡申请包含政府过去要求的所有内容。父亲赚的钱足够，父亲在工作，出示了他的纳税申报表。但孩子被拒绝了，因为政府说他会成为“公共负担”。
So we inquire and ask, we're not sure why this person has been denied. Could you provide more information? Still no explanation.
所以我们询问并寻求原因，我们不确定为什么此人被拒绝。你能提供更多信息吗？仍然没有解释。
All this has led Jacqueline Watson, and a lot of immigration attorneys, to conclude that, at this point--
这一切导致杰奎琳·沃森和许多移民律师得出结论，在这一点上——
The Department of Homeland Security is always looking for new and creative ways to fuck our clients.
国土安全部总是寻找新的、创造性的方法来操弄我们的客户。
There's a brand new way that Jacqueline's worried about. You know those Requests for Evidence that lawyers complained about? USCIS has a new rule. If they decide there isn't enough evidence to support a claim, as of this month, they don't need to issue a Request for Evidence at all. They could simply turn down the application.
杰奎琳担心的有一种全新的方式。你知道律师们抱怨的那些“补充证据请求”吗？USCIS有一项新规定。如果他们认为没有足够的证据支持一项主张，从本月开始，他们根本不需要发出“补充证据请求”。他们可以直接拒绝申请。
The head of USCIS, Francis Cissna, is quoted in the press release on this. He says, quote, "For too long, our immigration system has been bogged down with frivolous or meritless claims that slow down processing for everyone." He said, "Doing this would discourage people from gaming the system."
USCIS局长弗朗西斯·西斯纳在新闻发布会上被引用。他说：“长期以来，我们的移民系统一直被轻率或毫无根据的主张所困，这减慢了每个人的处理速度。”他说，“这样做会劝阻人们利用该系统。”
This is how all this looks to people on his side of things, the people calling for these changes and making these changes in our immigration system. They see every part of this so totally differently from the way the immigration attorneys do. From their point of view, the entire immigration system is a mess, overloaded with false claims and people trying to cheat their way into the United States.
这就是他的支持者们，那些呼吁这些变革并正在我们移民系统中做出这些变革的人如何看待这一切。他们看待这一切的方式与移民律师看待的方式完全不同。从他们的观点来看，整个移民系统是一团糟，充斥着虚假主张和试图欺骗进入美国的人。
When the Attorney General gives speeches, he talks about nearly 100,000 people a year seeking asylum. Seeking asylum because they know if you say the word asylum, we'll set you free in the United States till the judge can see your case years from now. Lots of them never show up for their day in court.
当司法部长发表演讲时，他谈到每年有近10万人寻求庇护。寻求庇护是因为他们知道如果你说了“庇护”这个词，我们就会放你在美国自由，直到法官几年后审理你的案件。他们中的许多人从未在法庭上露面。
The system is being gamed. There's no doubt about it.
该系统正在被操弄。毫无疑问。
Mark Krikorian is the executive director of the Center for Immigration Studies, a Washington think tank that calls for stricter controls on immigration. He makes the case that the United States would be better off if we would just cut the number of people who immigrate here each year to less than half of what it is now. He sums it up this way. He doesn't see a need for a huge, thriving country like ours, with hundreds of millions of people, to import any workers from overseas. So--
马克·克里科里安是移民研究中心（Center for Immigration Studies）的执行董事，这是一个呼吁对移民进行更严格控制的华盛顿智库。他提出了一个观点，即如果我们每年将移民到这里的人数减少到现在的一半以下，美国会更好。他这样总结。他不认为像我们这样拥有数亿人口的庞大、繁荣的国家有必要从海外输入任何工人。所以——
Which categories of people have such a compelling case to be admitted that we let them in? That would be husbands, wives, and little kids of American citizens, genuine Einsteins-- humanity has not produced that many Einsteins a year-- and humanitarian immigration to the extent that people cannot stay where they are for a second longer. You add all that up, that's maybe 400,000 people a year, 350,000. It's still a lot of people, but it's fewer than there are now.
哪些类别的人有如此令人信服的理由被接纳以至于我们让他们进来？那将是美国公民的丈夫、妻子和小孩，真正的爱因斯坦——人类每年没有产出那么多爱因斯坦——以及人道主义移民，前提是人们在原地一刻也无法停留。把所有这些加起来，每年也许40万人，35万人。这仍然很多人，但比现在少。
Right now, it's about a million legal immigrants in a year. Of course, you could quibble with his numbers. Somebody else might argue that there are over a million people in the category, "people who cannot stay where they are for a second longer."
现在，每年大约有100万合法移民。当然，你可以对他的数字提出异议。其他人可能会争辩说，在“在原地一刻也无法停留的人”这一类别中，有超过100万人。
But given this vision that we don't need outsiders, and that tons of people are trying to cheat and game their way into the country, when I told Krikorian what the immigration attorneys had told me about all the ways that the Trump administration seemed to be slowing things down and finding any excuse to say no to their clients, he was utterly unimpressed. He appreciated the tighter rules and extra scrutiny that have come down this last year and a half.
但鉴于我们不需要外来者，以及大量人试图欺骗和操弄进入该国的愿景，当我告诉克里科里安移民律师告诉我的关于特朗普政府似乎正在放慢速度并找任何借口拒绝他们的客户的所有方式时，他完全不为所动。他赞赏这一年半以来出现的更严格的规则和额外审查。
It's definitely called for. It's long overdue. Now, there's always going to be, you know, bureaucratic absurdities. Does the Archdiocese of San Antonio really exist? I mean, this is the kind of thing that any large organization is going to generate sometimes. But the strict scrutiny of applications is long, long overdue.
这绝对是有必要的。这早就该做了。现在，总会有官僚主义的荒谬之处。圣安东尼奥总教区真的存在吗？我的意思是，这是任何大型组织有时都会产生的那种事情。但对申请的严格审查是早就、早就该做的了。
More change is coming. One of the biggest ideas that's been floated publicly by the White House Office of Management and Budget is a proposal that you won't be able to get legal residency, you won't be able to get a green card or citizenship, if you or your kids have ever gotten food stamps or other public benefits. Even if your kids are citizens.
更多的变化即将来临。白宫管理和预算办公室公开提出的最大想法之一是一个提案，即如果你或你的孩子曾经获得过食品券或其他公共福利，你将无法获得合法居留权，你将无法获得绿卡或公民身份。即使你的孩子是公民。
If this went through, it would become impossible for millions of people to ever get legal status in this country. They become eligible for deportation. It's unclear, at this point, if the administration is going to go through with that proposal.
如果这获得通过，数百万人将不可能在这个国家获得合法身份。他们变得有资格被驱逐出境。目前尚不清楚政府是否会实施该提案。
Coming up, food fight between the President's immigration staffers, the State Department, the Office of Management and Budget, and the most powerful military the world has ever known. Guess who wins? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，总统的移民工作人员、国务院、管理和预算办公室以及世界上有史以来最强大的军队之间的“食物大战”。猜猜谁赢了？这在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. In today's program, "Let Me Count the Ways," we're trying to document the many, many ways that the Trump administration is changing immigration enforcement across many agencies, including some things that have not gotten a lot of attention. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, The Terminators.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目“让我数数方式”中，我们试图记录特朗普政府在许多机构中改变移民执法方式的许多许多方式，包括一些没有得到太多关注的事情。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。第三幕，终结者。
So the people directing immigration policy for the White House generally don't talk much to the press. They do the work behind the scenes and out of sight from the public. But some emails were released as part of a lawsuit, and they give us the most vivid picture we have gotten of these people at work, of them enacting the project that is at the heart of this administration.
所以，指挥白宫移民政策的人通常不会与媒体多交谈。他们在幕后工作，不被公众看见。但一些作为诉讼一部分发布的电子邮件，给了我们关于这些人工作、执行该政府核心项目的最生动的画面。
On immigration, probably more than anything, the President's agenda is a radical departure from any Republican or Democrat who's ever held the office. He complains frequently about the bureaucracy, the deep state trying to thwart him. And in these emails, you see the battle play out between the political appointees and the bureaucracy.
关于移民，可能比任何其他事情都更能说明问题的是，总统的议程是对任何曾经担任过该职位的共和党人或民主党人的彻底背离。他经常抱怨官僚机构，抱怨试图阻挠他的“深层政府”。而在这些电子邮件中，你看到了政治任命人员与官僚机构之间的斗争。
The emails show them trying to roll back one particular part of immigration policy, a part that could result in half a million people having to leave the United States. In these emails, the appointee's tone is almost uniformly polite, professional. The career civil servants ask to handle things so differently than they have in the past. They push back respectfully in various ways. One of our producers, Nadia Reiman, read all the emails, which took days, and put this together.
这些电子邮件显示他们试图回滚移民政策的某一部分，这一部分可能导致50万人不得不离开美国。在这些电子邮件中，任命人员的语气几乎统一地礼貌、专业。职业公务员要求以与过去完全不同的方式处理事情。他们以各种方式礼貌地反击。我们的制片人之一纳迪亚·雷曼读了所有电子邮件，这花了几天时间，并将这整理在一起。
The emails were about this thing called TPS, Temporary Protected Status. It's a humanitarian program, and it works like this. If you're in the US and some sort of disaster hits your home country-- an earthquake or hurricane, or a war breaks out-- the Secretary of Homeland Security can grant temporary protected status, which means, we get it. You can't go back to your country right now. So stick around for 18 months or so. You can get a work permit, live here, settle for a bit until things clear up at home.
这些电子邮件是关于一种叫做TPS的东西，即“临时保护身份”。这是一种人道主义计划，运作方式如下。如果你在美国，而你的祖国发生了某种灾难——地震或飓风，或爆发了战争——国土安全部部长可以授予临时保护身份，这意味着，我们理解。你现在不能回到你的国家。所以待上18个月左右。你可以获得工作许可，住在这里，安定下来，直到家里的事情清理干净。
The President's allies don't like TPS for a couple of reasons. First, it's not just for people who are here legally. If you're here illegally when disaster hits your home country, congrats, you get legal status, too. Also, even though it's called temporary, it can get renewed over and over and over again. Honduras, for example, got hit by a hurricane in 1998, and it still has TPS almost 20 years later.
总统的盟友不喜欢TPS有两个原因。首先，它不仅针对那些合法在这里的人。如果你在祖国发生灾难时是非法在这里的，恭喜你，你也获得了合法身份。此外，虽然它被称为“临时”，但它可以被一次又一次地续签。例如，洪都拉斯在1998年遭受了飓风袭击，几乎20年后它仍然有TPS。
And these renewals, they're up to the Department of Homeland Security. Every year, they're supposed to gather information to try to figure out, has the country recovered? Is it safe for people to return home or not? If it is, they can end TPS for that country, but it's up to DHS to decide.
而这些续签，由国土安全部决定。每年，他们应该收集信息试图搞清楚，国家恢复了吗？人们现在回家安全吗？如果安全，他们可以结束该国的TPS，但这由国土安全部决定。
So for Trump political appointees to get rid of TPS for a country, what they have to do is prove that the country has recovered from whatever crisis it once had. They have to prove it's safe for people to go home.
所以对于特朗普的政治任命人员来说，要废除一个国家的TPS，他们必须做的是证明该国已经从曾经经历的任何危机中恢复过来。他们必须证明人们回家是安全的。
The first country they try it with is Haiti. Haiti got TPS eight years ago when that earthquake hit in 2010. In the first months of the Trump administration, the bureaucracy put together a report that said, basically, what they'd said in the past. Things are still bad in Haiti. Let's renew TPS. 18 more months please.
他们尝试的第一个国家是海地。海地在8年前2010年地震发生时获得了TPS。在特朗普政府的最初几个月里，官僚机构整理了一份报告，基本上说了他们过去说过的话。海地的情况仍然很糟糕。让我们续签TPS。请再来18个月。
This is when a Trump appointee named Kathy Nuebel Kovarik enters the scene. Before this job, she did immigration policy for Senator Chuck Grassley, an anti-immigration hardliner who then urged the President to hire her, on Twitter. So in April 2017, she sends out an email saying, basically, can anyone hustle up info on how Haiti's recovered from the earthquake? She asked for, quote, "rebuilding stories, work of nonprofits, how the US is helping in certain industries. We need more than Haiti is really horror stories." End quote.
这时，一位名叫凯西·纽贝尔·科瓦里克的特朗普任命人员登场了。在从事这份工作之前，她为参议员查克·格拉斯利（一名反移民强硬派，后来在推特上敦促总统雇佣她）制定移民政策。所以在2017年4月，她发了一封电子邮件，基本上是说，有谁能赶紧弄到关于海地如何从地震中恢复的信息吗？她要求，“重建故事、非营利组织的工作、美国在某些行业如何提供帮助。我们需要的不只是海地的恐怖故事。”
A researcher chimes in, unhelpfully. Quote, "Unfortunately, conditions in Haiti remain difficult. Please see below." And he goes on to share five bullet points. The first one, Haiti has not fully recovered from the 2010 earthquake. He also mentions hurricanes that have hit the island, large scale flooding, near-famine conditions, double-digit inflation. He gets a polite, "Thank you. Very useful," from his boss.
一位研究人员无济于事地插话。引用：“不幸的是，海地的情况仍然困难。请见下文。”他继续分享了五个要点。第一点，海地尚未从2010年地震中完全恢复。他还提到了袭击该岛的飓风、大规模洪水、近乎饥荒的情况、两位数的通货膨胀。他得到了老板礼貌的回复：“谢谢。非常有帮助。”
Before long, he gets asked for more info. Can you grab more numbers on GDP growth? You said it was not so good, but can you look at longer-term trends? What about some stuff about how they're rebuilding the presidential palace? Can you try that? If there's much of a fight about any of this, it's not on email.
不久，他被要求提供更多信息。你能抓取更多关于GDP增长的数字吗？你说它不那么好，但你能看看更长期的趋势吗？关于他们如何重建总统府的一些东西怎么样？你能试一试吗？如果关于这一切有什么争执，那也不会在电子邮件里。
Eventually, the staffers find some new numbers for their bosses. They know that economic growth is small, but it's there; that 98% of camps for earthquake survivors are now closed; that food shortages in the country are because of hurricanes and bad infrastructure, not necessarily related to the earthquake. In November, it's officially announced. Haitians lose their protected status. One country down, onto the next.
最终，工作人员为他们的老板找到了一些新数字。他们知道经济增长很小，但确实存在；98%的地震幸存者营地现在已经关闭；该国的食物短缺是因为飓风和糟糕的基础设施，并不一定与地震有关。11月，正式宣布。海地人失去了他们的保护身份。解决了一个国家，转向下一个。
Next up is Sudan. And here is where this becomes a full-blown smackdown between three federal agencies-- Homeland Security, State Department, and the Department of Defense. Sudan's had TPS since 1997 because of the civil war there. There's still widespread fighting in parts of the country. So when its TPS status comes up for review, a couple of staffers put together a draft of the country conditions, describing what it's like there, and it's pretty grim.
接下来是苏丹。这里发生了一场涉及三个联邦机构——国土安全部、国务院和国防部——的全面冲突。苏丹自1997年以来因为那里的内战一直有TPS。该国部分地区仍然有广泛的战斗。所以当其TPS状态需要审查时，几名工作人员起草了一份关于国家条件的草案，描述那里是什么样子，而且相当严峻。
Page three says it's, quote, "unsafe for individuals to return to Sudan." On page four it says, quote, "Termination does not appear to be warranted," meaning Sudan's status should not be terminated. People should be allowed to stay in the US. But then, on page five, when we get to the final recommendation, it says exactly the opposite. Quote, "USCIS recommends termination."
第三页说，引用：“个人返回苏丹不安全。”在第四页，它说，引用：“终止似乎没有正当理由”，这意味着不应该终止苏丹的身份。人们应该被允许留在美国。但随后，在第五页，当我们看到最终建议时，它说的恰恰相反。引用：“USCIS建议终止。”
The higher-ups noticed this discrepancy and realized how it might look. Frank Cissna, the guy who's been tapped to be the new director of USCIS, another Trump political appointee, he reads the country report for Sudan and writes, quote, "The memo reads like one person who strongly supports extending TPS wrote everything up to the recommendations section, and then someone who opposes extensions snuck up behind the first guy, clubbed him over the head, pushed his senseless body out of the way, and finished the memo. Am I missing something?" End quote.
高层注意到了这种差异，并意识到它可能看起来是什么样子。弗兰克·西斯纳，那个被选为USCIS新局长（另一位特朗普政治任命人员）的人，他阅读了苏丹的国家报告并写道，引用：“这份备忘录读起来就像一个人强烈支持延长TPS，写完了建议部分之前的所有内容，然后一个反对延期的人从第一个家伙后面溜上来，用棍子打他的头，把他无知觉的身体推开，完成了备忘录。我遗漏了什么吗？”
Right away, political appointee Kathy Nuebel Kovarik is like, sorry about that. She responds, quote, "Well, I'll take the blame for this," and sends it to someone on her team to fix, a career civil servant named Brandon Prelogar.
很快，政治任命人员凯西·纽贝尔·科瓦里克就像，抱歉。她回应道，引用：“好吧，我对此承担责任”，并将其发给她团队中的一个人去修复，一名叫布兰登·普雷洛加的职业公务员。
Prelogar didn't respond to my request for an interview. The administration officials in these emails didn't either. But I can tell you a few things about him.
普雷洛加没有回应我的采访请求。这些电子邮件中的政府官员也没有。但我可以告诉你关于他的一些事情。
He's the Chief for international and humanitarian affairs at USCIS. He's been working for the Department of Homeland Security since 2007 through both Bush and Obama, which depending on how you look at it, makes him either an operative for the deep state trying to thwart our President at every turn, or a typical DC civil servant trying to do his job.
他是USCIS国际和人道主义事务主管。自2007年以来，他一直在国土安全部工作，经历了布什和奥巴马时期，根据你看待它的方式，这使他要么是试图在每一步阻挠我们总统的“深层政府”特工，要么是一个努力做他工作的典型华盛顿公务员。
Throughout all these emails, every so often he pops up, calmly raising his hand and reminding everyone of the rules. He's not standing in the way, exactly. It's more like he's fact checking, waving his arms, politely warning of trouble ahead. Saying, well, you can try to do that, but the facts might not be with you. He has this thing he writes over and over, like an existential truth. "Country conditions are what they are."
在所有这些电子邮件中，每隔一段时间他就会蹦出来，冷静地举起手，提醒每个人规则。他不是确切地站在路上。这更像是在核对事实，挥手示意，礼貌地警告前方的麻烦。说，嗯，你可以尝试那样做，但事实可能不支持你。他有一件事一遍又一遍地写，就像一个存在主义的真理。“国家条件就是那样。”
Anyway, he's assigned to fix the inconsistent memo ASAP. He responds, "Got it. Here's our thinking. The country conditions are what they are. If they're uncomfortable with the termination conclusion following from them and they want to stick with that conclusion, we've proposed paring down that section." End quote. In other words, if the conclusion doesn't match the facts, then your best bet is to remove some of the facts.
总之，他被分配去尽快修复不一致的备忘录。他回应道：“明白了。这是我们的想法。国家条件就是那样。如果他们对随之而来的终止结论感到不舒服，并且他们想坚持那个结论，我们建议削减那一部分。”换句话说，如果结论与事实不符，那么你最好的选择就是删除一些事实。
He sends possible wording they could use to do that, but warns, quote, "Providing sanitized country conditions in a public-facing document would open us up to the charge that our account is lopsided and invite criticism." He passes the draft back to his boss. It goes through more hands, and then it gets to one of the big guns in the Department of Homeland Security, a senior staffer named Gene Hamilton.
他发出了他们可以用来做这件事的措辞，但警告说，引用：“在公开文件中提供经过修饰的国家条件会使我们容易受到我们的陈述是不平衡的指控，并招致批评。”他把草案传回给他的老板。它经过更多人的手，然后到达了国土安全部的大人物之一，一名名叫吉恩·汉密尔顿的高级工作人员。
Gene Hamilton's a political appointee. He was the person responsible for immigration policy in the transition team. He worked with Stephen Miller back in the Senate in Jeff Sessions's office. So he takes this Sudan report and he removes even more facts than Brandon suggested. Specifically, he edits out references to human rights violations.
吉恩·汉密尔顿是一位政治任命人员。他是过渡团队中负责移民政策的人。他在参议院与斯蒂芬·米勒在杰夫·塞申斯的办公室工作。所以他拿走了这份苏丹报告，删除了比布兰登建议更多的事实。具体来说，他删除了关于侵犯人权的参考。
When Brandon sees the results, he once again respectfully raises a red flag. He's like, guys, based on what they've said so far, the State Department is probably not going to like that. He adds, quote, "For our part, we just say that this could be read as taking another step toward providing an incomplete and lopsided country conditions presentation to support termination." The email trail goes dead. Six days later, DHS announces they're terminating TPS for Sudan.
当布兰登看到结果时，他再次礼貌地举起红旗。他就像，伙计们，根据他们迄今为止所说的，国务院可能不会喜欢那个。他补充说，引用：“就我们而言，我们只是说这可能被解读为迈向提供不完整和不平衡的国家条件陈述以支持终止的又一步。”电子邮件踪迹变冷了。六天后，国土安全部宣布他们正在终止苏丹的TPS。
The next day, the State Department complains, just like Brandon said they would. They say the TPS report had, quote, "significant mischaracterizations that are at odds with the State Department's understanding of circumstances on the ground in Sudan." They complained they hadn't been notified of the Sudan TPS termination. That they had to find out about this when everyone else did. That they had to send diplomats in cabs to the embassies to do damage control.
第二天，国务院抱怨，就像布兰登说的那样。他们说TPS报告有“重大误读，与国务院对苏丹当地情况的理解不符。”他们抱怨他们没有被通知苏丹TPS终止。他们必须在其他人发现时才发现。他们必须派外交官乘坐出租车去大使馆进行损害控制。
Then a White House official steps in. He writes Gene Hamilton to say that they'd received a, quote, "flurry of emails from the State Department and the National Security Council about the Sudan decision." He tells Gene Hamilton to go back to the language that the State Department and everyone else agreed to the week before.
然后一位白宫官员介入。他写信给吉恩·汉密尔顿说，他们收到了“来自国务院和国家安全委员会关于苏丹决定的一连串电子邮件。”他告诉吉恩·汉密尔顿回到国务院和所有人上周同意的语言。
Gene Hamilton writes back to the White House official, defiant, cc-ing all the bosses at DHS, quote, "I don't think we agree with that path." The White House doesn't write back. Less than an hour later, Gene sends another email to the same White House guy and caves. Hi again, he says. We will pull back, though, he says, many of the concerns are, quote, "entirely overblown and completely irrelevant."
吉恩·汉密尔顿写信回复给白宫官员，挑衅地抄送了国土安全部的所有老板，引用：“我不认为我们同意那条路径。”白宫没有回信。不到一小时后，吉恩给同一个白宫家伙发了另一封电子邮件并屈服了。他再次说，你好。我们会退缩，虽然他说，许多担忧是，“完全夸大且完全无关紧要的。”
The next day, the Department of Defense weighs in. A foreign affairs specialist sends an email. It begins, "It has been brought to our attention," and the tone of utter disapproval never lets up. She says the Sudan memo is wrong about conditions in Sudan. That armed conflict is ongoing. It's not safe for Sudanese to return there.
第二天，国防部发表了意见。一位外交事务专家发了一封电子邮件。它以“我们的注意力被带到了这一点”开始，彻底不赞同的语气从未停止。她说苏丹备忘录对苏丹的情况是错误的。武装冲突正在进行中。苏丹人返回那里不安全。
She says what they've written is, quote, "a clear departure to past DOD messaging on Darfur to our Congressional committees and foreign partners." She says the Department of Defense would appreciate being included in any policy discussions that impact Sudan.
她说他们所写的是，引用：“与过去国防部在达尔富尔问题上向我们的国会委员会和外国伙伴发布的信息的明显背离。”她说国防部如果被包括在任何影响苏丹的政策讨论中将会非常感激。
There are more emails after that, and in the end, Gene Hamilton does make a small concession. A few sentences get added back to the Sudan memo. But the result is still the same. TPS for Sudan is ended. The new guard wins.
在那之后还有更多的电子邮件，最后，吉恩·汉密尔顿确实做出了小小的让步。几句话被加回了苏丹备忘录。但结果仍然是一样的。苏丹的TPS结束了。新卫队赢了。
One by one, the countries in these emails lose TPS. After Sudan comes Nicaragua. Soon it's El Salvador, Nepal, Honduras. The administration ended up terminating TPS for 98% of the people who had it.
一个接一个，这些电子邮件中的国家失去了TPS。苏丹之后是尼加拉瓜。很快是萨尔瓦多、尼泊尔、洪都拉斯。政府最终终止了98%拥有TPS的人的TPS。
I talk to government officials who've dealt with TPS, and they all said TPS was messy. That it was something temporary that became permanent, and it probably shouldn't have. But at the same time, an enormous number of people are currently living here on TPS. Over 400,000. Most of them have been here legally for almost 20 years.
我和处理过TPS的政府官员交谈，他们都说TPS很乱。它是暂时的却变成了永久的，而且可能本不该如此。但与此同时，有大量的人目前正以TPS生活在这里。超过40万。他们大多数人几乎20年来一直合法在这里。
Inevitably, a whole new life grows out of two decades of just being somewhere. People start businesses, buy houses, get married, have kids. And these kids, the sons and daughters of TPS recipients, US citizens, they're part of the lawsuit that released all these emails. They're suing the government over this very mess so their parents aren't sent back home to a place that isn't their home anymore.
不可避免地，一种全新的生活在二十年的仅仅是“呆在某处”中生长出来。人们开始创业、买房、结婚、生孩子。而这些孩子，TPS受益人的儿子和女儿，美国公民，他们是释放所有这些电子邮件的诉讼的一部分。他们正在为这场烂摊子起诉政府，以便他们的父母不会被遣送回一个不再是他们家的地方。
Nadia Reiman. She's one of the producers of our show. Act Four, IRC You, Now You Don't. The President has cut the number of refugees officially allowed into the United States from 110,000, under the previous administration, to 45,000. But in fact, in this fiscal year, they're not even going to bring in that many people. Just 22,000 will arrive. That's the smallest number ever in the history of the refugee program here.
纳迪亚·雷曼。她是我们的节目制片人之一。第四幕，IRC你，现在你不。总统已经将正式允许进入美国的难民数量从前任政府时期的11万人削减到了4.5万人。但实际上，在这个财年中，他们甚至不会引进那么多人。只有2.2万人会抵达。这是这里难民计划历史上人数最少的一次。
So a bunch of these refugee settlement offices that are around the country are going to be shutting down. Our producer, Zoe Chace, was there for the final days of one of them in Garden City, Kansas.
所以全国各地的这些难民安置办公室将要关闭。我们的制片人，佐伊·切斯，在那里见证了位于堪萨斯州加登城其中一个办公室的最后几天。
I flew into a tiny airport. Garden City is southwest Kansas, the middle of the plains. Oklahoma's right below us. Colorado's not far west. Amy Longa was waiting there at the airport. She started the office four years ago for the International Rescue Committee. She told me I'd recognize her, and I did. The only black woman there. Straight back, tall, and a bright turquoise African print dress.
我飞进了一个小机场。加登城是堪萨斯州西南部，平原的中间。俄克拉荷马州就在我们下面。科罗拉多州也不远，在西边。艾米·朗加在机场等着。她四年前为国际救援委员会（IRC）开了这个办公室。她告诉我我会认出她来，我也确实认出来了。那里唯一的黑人女性。背挺直，个子高，穿着一件明亮的绿松石色非洲印花连衣裙。
Everyone recognizes Amy. I'll find out soon then even Amy refers to herself in the third person a lot. Like, she'll say, everybody knows Amy. I can't get away because it's, like, Amy, Amy, Amy everywhere I go.
每个人都认识艾米。我很快发现即使是艾米也经常用第三人称称呼自己。比如，她说，每个人都知道艾米。我无法逃脱，因为我无论走到哪里，都是“艾米、艾米、艾米”。
And truly, like, the kid at the Hertz counter called out to her. Amy, have you seen this? And handed her a flyer for some kind of Hertz deal. It's like the character Amy plays in this town is bigger than Amy actually is.
而且确实，就像赫兹柜台的孩子喊住她。艾米，你见过这个吗？并递给她一份某种赫兹交易的传单。就好像艾米在这个小镇扮演的角色比艾米本人还要大。
It's Tuesday, July 24. The office is supposed to close on Friday. I follow Amy in my rental car and when I get there, the office looks wrecked. Cardboard boxes, an abandoned paper shredder, an old car seat. I mean, it looks closed. But Amy's in the middle of a meeting, in Arabic.
那是7月24日星期二。办公室定于星期五关闭。我开着租来的车跟着艾米，当我到达那里时，办公室看起来很破烂。纸箱、废弃的碎纸机、旧汽车座椅。我的意思是，它看起来已经关闭了。但艾米正在进行一场会议，用阿拉伯语。
She and one of her clients are sitting in two office chairs pulled up near the door. Where you'd expect a desk between them, they're just knee to knee in these rolly chairs. The client's name is Eltahir. He's from Sudan. He's apparently asking Amy to help him figure out why he got his federal tax refund, but not his state one. Amy takes the papers he brought. Says she'll look into it.
她和她的客户之一坐在门边拉着的两把办公椅上。在你期望他们中间有一张桌子的地方，他们只是在这些滚轮椅上膝盖碰膝盖。客户的名字叫埃尔塔希尔。他来自苏丹。他显然是在请求艾米帮他弄清楚为什么他收到了联邦退税，但没有收到州退税。艾米拿着他带来的文件。说她会调查一下。
OK. Now, are you comfortable leaving this with me and we make appointment tomorrow?
好的。现在，你介意把它留给我，我们明天预约一下吗？
OK.
好的。
What do you want to do? I can't-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
你想做什么？我不能——[外语演讲]
I'm looking around at this abandoned office and Amy and I'm like, what? Appointment tomorrow?
我看着这个废弃的办公室和艾米，我就想，什么？明天预约？
OK. So why are you still having these conversations if you're going to be closed in two days?
好的。那么如果两天后就要关闭，你为什么还要进行这些对话？
Because technically, the office is still open. The office is open.
因为严格来说，办公室仍然开放。办公室是开放的。
You're the only one here.
这里只有你一个人。
I am the only one. And I'm here.
我是一个人。但我在这里。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm supposed to have packed all these. And I-- it's difficult to pack when you still have to answer these questions.
我应该把这些都打包好的。我——当必须回答这些问题时，打包很困难。
Refugee resettlement is exactly what you'd imagine, if you've ever thought about it. You do a bunch of interviews overseas, go through a major security screening process. You fly to the United States, someone meets you at the airport and takes you to your new home.
难民安置正是你想象的那样，如果你曾经想过的话。你在海外进行一系列面试，通过主要的背景调查过程。你飞往美国，有人在机场接你并把你带到你的新家。
The US government funds a sparse apartment with food that's culturally relevant, like food that will be familiar to you, as well as cash assistance, housing assistance. This lasts for three months while you look for work and go through some cultural orientation. And all this is managed by a resettlement agency, a nonprofit that contracts with the State Department to do this stuff.
美国政府资助一套简朴的公寓，提供符合文化的食物，比如你熟悉的食物，以及现金援助、住房援助。这持续三个月，同时你寻找工作并进行一些文化适应。所有这些都由一家安置机构管理，这是一家与国务院签约做这些事的非营利组织。
In Garden City, it's the International Rescue Committee, the IRC. They help you get a social security card, figure out your health insurance, find a job, go learn English. Pretty much all the things that make up a life here. Three months. 90 days. I do wonder how they came up with that. Making a whole life in 90 days.
在加登城，是国际救援委员会（IRC）。他们帮助你获得社会安全卡、搞清楚你的健康保险、找到一份工作、去学习英语。基本上所有构成这里生活的事情。三个月。90天。我确实想知道他们是怎么想出那个的。在90天内创造一个完整的生活。
The IRC office works with their clients for up to five years with some government assistance. Most of Amy's time is spent with clients far longer than 90 days. This guy from Sudan, he's been here two years. This office is being closed because so few refugees will be relocated here in the future. But the fact is, Amy is right in the middle of these relationships, and she has to cut them off.
IRC办公室与他们的客户合作长达五年，有一些政府援助。艾米的大部分时间花在远超90天的客户身上。这个来自苏丹的家伙，他已经在这里两年了。这个办公室被关闭是因为未来搬迁到这里的难民很少。但事实是，艾米正处于这些关系的核心，她必须切断它们。
The people who are resettled here have a never-ending range of questions. For instance, this is Edie. He came to Garden City recently via a refugee camp in Tanzania. He's Congolese. He's a very giggly guy, but I think it's nerves.
在这里安置的人有无穷无尽的问题。例如，这是伊迪。他最近通过坦桑尼亚的难民营来到加登城。他是刚果人。他是一个非常爱笑的家伙，但我认为那是紧张。
He comes in, sits down with Amy, and unfolds a paper with four questions on it. One is about a guy not calling him back with a job. Another is about a bank card. How do you use it? He didn't have a pin number. Didn't know what a pin was. She activates it.
他走进来，和艾米坐下，展开一张纸，上面有四个问题。一个是关于一个没回他求职电话的家伙。另一个是关于银行卡。你怎么使用它？他没有密码。不知道密码是什么。她激活了它。
Activated.
已激活。
Thank you, madam. [INAUDIBLE] now. It was good.
谢谢，女士。[听不清]现在。很好。
There's a church question, a health insurance question, then he thinks of two more.
有一个教堂问题，一个健康保险问题，然后他又想到了两个。
Another question now please. Sorry.
现在请问另一个问题。抱歉。
It's like this all the time. How do I get a birth certificate for my new baby daughter? How much does it cost? How is my green card application doing? Do they need more information? Is my boss racist? Then why isn't he responding?
一直都是这样。我怎么为我的新女婴获得出生证明？要多少钱？我的绿卡申请进展如何？他们需要更多信息吗？我的老板是种族主义者吗？那他为什么不回复？
How much is it to go to the dentist? Should I pull this tooth out of my mouth? If I pull the tooth, should I replace it with a new tooth or leave the gap? And what will people around here think if I have a gap? Is that bad? Where is the dentist's office?
去看牙医要多少钱？我应该把这颗牙从嘴里拔掉吗？如果我拔了牙，我是应该换一颗新牙还是留着缺口？周围的人如果我有一个缺口会怎么想？那很糟糕吗？牙医办公室在哪里？
One night, Amy's meeting with this guy at his apartment. And when she's done, this other guy, who's not even a client, runs after her and yells at her from a balcony that he needs to talk. And she's got three days left in this job, but she makes an appointment with him, too. And again, I'm like, why are you meeting with this guy? Like, where is he going to sit even?
一天晚上，艾米在他的公寓里和他见面。当她做完时，另一个甚至不是客户的家伙从阳台上追赶她并对她大喊，他需要谈谈。她在工作中只剩下三天了，但她也和他预约了。再一次，我就想，你为什么要和这个家伙见面？比如，他甚至要去哪里坐？
He walked out of that house. I'm sure he knew-- we were in the sitting room. He knew the IRC is there, or Amy. And as we moved out, he got out to the balcony and said, I'm going to take this chance and ask. If it was not something important, he wouldn't have pushed the button that far.
他走出那所房子。我相信他知道——我们在客厅。他知道IRC在那里，或者艾米。当我们走出来时，他走到阳台上说，我要抓住这个机会问一下。如果不是重要的事情，他不会把按钮推得那么远。
Amy has this ability where it's like she imagines all the thoughts in their head. She can picture the entire thought process of the person who's sitting in front of her.
艾米有一种能力，就好像她能想象出他们头脑中所有的想法。她能画出坐在她面前的人的整个思维过程。
He just didn't jump out and run. He chewed it. He digested it.
他只是没有跳出来跑掉。他咀嚼了它。他消化了它。
Mm-hmm. That's your problem, I think. You can imagine everybody's reality too closely.
嗯。我认为那是你的问题。你可以太近距离地想象每个人的现实。
Amy has been a displaced person. First from Uganda, then to Sudan. She ended up in Khartoum. Then she had to flee Khartoum. Then back to Uganda where she was displaced again, until she went to college in the capital city Kampala. Then she worked for the UN, then she came to the US.
艾米曾是一个流离失所的人。先是从乌干达，然后到苏丹。她在喀土穆结束。然后她不得不逃离喀土穆。然后回到乌干达，在那里她再次流离失所，直到她在首都坎帕拉上大学。然后她在联合国工作，然后她来到美国。
When Amy's office closes on Friday, Edie and the others will still have somewhere to go. They're getting hooked up with a local branch of Catholic Charities, a nonprofit that stepped in to fill this gap, to close out the 90 days of whoever's left. They've never done this work before, though, so it's been kind of trial by fire, more people than they expected.
当艾米的办公室周五关闭时，伊迪和其他人仍然有地方可去。他们正在与天主教慈善机构（Catholic Charities）的一个当地分会取得联系，这是一个介入填补这个空白的非营利组织，来结束剩下任何人的90天期限。不过，他们从未做过这项工作，所以这有点像“烈火淬炼”，比他们预期的人数更多。
And they admit, they don't offer the suite of services and care that the IRC does. And they do not have caseworkers who were themselves displaced people in Africa.
他们承认，他们不提供IRC那样的服务和护理套件。而且他们没有本身就是非洲流离失所者的个案工作者。
When I talked to them, they copped to that. Yes, it's been hard. And no, we do not have the unique instinct of Amy Longa. So it's going to be different. Edie, who comes here at least three times a week, wants to know how to reach Amy after the office closes.
当我与他们交谈时，他们承认了这一点。是的，这很困难。而且不，我们没有艾米·朗加独特的本能。所以这会不同。每周至少来这里三次的伊迪想知道在办公室关闭后如何联系艾米。
No, I'm not giving you my cell phone number and I cannot give you my address. But Garden City's small. I can guarantee you we will meet somewhere.
不，我不会给你我的手机号码，我也不能给你我的地址。但加登城很小。我可以保证我们会在这某处见面。
There was this one meeting I saw Amy have with a client that I will never forget.
我见过艾米与一位客户进行过一次会议，我永远不会忘记。
Hey. How are you, bubba?
嘿。你好吗，哥们？
This kid, Norkamal, he's just a kid, really. 19 years old. He's Rohingya Muslim from Myanmar. The Rohingyas have been brutally persecuted there. He fled to Bangladesh, then Malaysia, then he came to the United States not being able to speak.
这个孩子，诺卡马尔，他真的只是个孩子。19岁。他是来自缅甸的罗兴亚穆斯林。罗兴亚人在那里遭受了残酷的迫害。他逃到了孟加拉国，然后是马来西亚，然后他来到美国时无法说话。
It's almost like he has no vocal cords at all. He's injured. I don't know how or why. Like, he really can't talk. He talks like this. Like, if you just made a K sound at the back of your throat. It's a whisper. (WHISPERING) "Ka." He also can't read much or write at all.
简直就像他根本没有声带一样。他受伤了。我不知道是怎么回事或为什么。比如，他真的不能说话。他说话是这样的。就像，如果你只是在喉咙后部发出一个K声。这是一种耳语。（耳语）“卡”。他也不会读多少，更写不了字。
Nor and Amy have gotten very close this year. It's almost like a mother-son relationship. Nor wants to get a surgery, a risky surgery, that could bring his voice back. He has health insurance, but it still took him a year and a half working in a beef slaughterhouse to save up $6,000 for the co-pay. Except, of course, his consultation with the doctor is for August 1.
诺和艾米今年变得非常亲密。这几乎像是一种母子关系。诺想做手术，一次风险手术，可能会带回他的声音。他有健康保险，但他仍然在牛肉屠宰场工作了一年半才存下6000美元用于共同支付。除了，当然，他与医生的咨询是在8月1日。
August 1. the day after Amy's office closes, when she's no longer technically supposed to be working with them. Though, of course, she'll still be his contact with the hospital. It's taken them all year to perfect their communication, and it's intimate watching them. It's kind of a lip reading, and signing, and looking into each other's eyes. He shows her some medical records she told him to find.
8月1日。艾米办公室关闭后的那天，当她不再被技术上要求与他们合作时。虽然，当然，她仍然会是他与医院的联系人。他们花了一整年来完善他们的交流，看着他们很亲密。这有点像读唇语，和签名，和看着对方的眼睛。他给她看了一些她告诉他找到的医疗记录。
You kept it together. I think this is it. You see, it's from the hospital in Malaysia.
你把它整理在一起了。我想这就是它。你看，它来自马来西亚的医院。
They sit cross-legged from each other on the floor. Amy's desk was literally just pulled out from under her. Some guys came and picked it up as a donation.
他们在地板上盘腿坐着。艾米的桌子确实刚被从她身下抽走。有些人来把它当作捐赠品拿走了。
Let's give it to the doctor, OK? Don't open it. Don't put anything in it. This is for the--
把它给医生吧，好吗？别打开它。别往里面放任何东西。这是给——
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
That's him saying, "the doctor."
那是他说“医生”。
When?
什么时候？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Wednesday.
周三。
Wednesday. Perfect. Bingo.
周三。完美。宾果。
Amy's clients. Lots of them non-English speaking, unskilled labor job having, expensive surgery booking. This is where the immigration debate lives. President Trump's idea, the idea of America First, it kind of means fewer people like this. Why can't we take care of the people in America first?
艾米的客户。许多人不懂英语，有不熟练的劳工工作，预订昂贵的手术。这就是移民辩论生活的地方。特朗普总统的想法，即“美国优先”的想法，它意味着更少像这样的人。为什么我们不能先照顾美国的人？
Trump supporters have said that to me for years now. That they think refugees take American jobs. They cost taxpayers too much money, these government grants to resettle refugees. This county in Kansas went 63% for Trump, so I figure a lot of people here like his policies. I found one of them on Facebook being skeptical of refugees. Then I found her in real life--
特朗普的支持者多年来一直对我这么说。他们认为难民抢走了美国人的工作。他们花纳税人太多钱，这些用于重新安置难民的政府补助金。堪萨斯州的这个县63%投给了特朗普，所以我认为很多人喜欢他的政策。我在脸书上发现其中一个对难民持怀疑态度。然后我在现实生活中发现了她——
All right. Let me come a little closer.
好吧。让我再靠近一点。
--in a farmhouse just past the meatpacking plant. She and her husband were sitting in their garage watching baseball, drinking beers, throwing the cans into the corner.
——在肉类加工厂外的一个农舍里。她和她的丈夫坐在车库里看着棒球，喝着啤酒，把罐子扔进角落里。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
OK. So who are you, sir?
好的。那么你是谁，长官？
My name's John Becker.
我的名字是约翰·贝克。
OK. And Mr. Becker, what do you make of this refugee resettlement office closing?
好的。贝克先生，你认为这个难民安置办公室关闭怎么样？
I don't even know what it is.
我甚至不知道它是什么。
OK. So you know refugees come into Garden City, Kansas, right?
好的。那么你知道难民来到堪萨斯州加登城，对吧？
Refugees?
难民？
Refugees.
难民。
What does that mean?
那意味着什么？
OK. What's a refugee? A refugee is like, basically, they've been-- they're coming from a war-torn country. Somalia, the Congo, Sudan, stuff like that.
好的。什么是难民？难民就像，基本上，他们被——他们来自饱受战争蹂躏的国家。索马里、刚果、苏丹之类的地方。
I don't buy that. I don't believe that.
我不买那账。我不相信那个。
OK. Well, I'll just tell you the definition of it first and--
好的。嗯，我会先告诉你它的定义，然后——
I don't believe that.
我不相信那个。
OK. And they get vetted extensively.
好的。而且他们经过了广泛的审查。
I don't believe that either.
我也不相信那个。
You don't believe the vetting thing.
你不相信审查那件事。
No. I don't believe they're vetted either.
不。我也不相信他们经过审查。
Right. Well, I guess the distinction that I just do want to make, though, is that they are here legally. It's not illegal immigration. You know, they have permission to be here. They're flown over here by the UN and State Department.
好的。好吧，我想我确实想要做出的区别是，他们是合法在这里的。这不是非法移民。你知道，他们有许可在这里。他们是被联合国和国务院飞到这里的。
Why are they doing that?
为什么他们那样做？
Well, because, you know, they're refugees. They can't go home.
嗯，因为，你知道，他们是难民。他们不能回家。
Why can't they?
为什么他们不能？
Because their home is unsafe.
因为他们的家不安全。
Oh, I don't buy that. I don't believe that either.
哦，我不买那账。我也不相信那个。
Why don't you believe it?
为什么你不相信它？
I just don't believe all that stuff.
我只是不相信所有那些东西。
John Becker is not the first person I've met who wants a moratorium on refugees. He is the first one who doesn't seem to believe in them, like they're unicorns or elves.
约翰·贝克不是我遇到的第一个想要暂停难民的人。他是第一个似乎不相信他们存在的人，就像他们是独角兽或精灵一样。
Well, it seems to me that now that they're closing down the office, there'll be fewer refugees here. Somebody is seeing things the way you are.
嗯，在我看来，既然他们要关闭办公室，这里难民会更少。有人正在像你一样看问题。
So there's going to be few of them? Fewer?
所以会少一些吗？更少？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, well, I applaud that.
哦，好吧，我为那个鼓掌。
It's the Trump administration.
这是特朗普政府。
We don't want to change our whole society here just for a few refugees. We don't want to do that.
我们不想为了几个难民就改变我们的整个社会。我们不想那样做。
They can go to a bigger town, bigger city maybe.
他们可以去一个更大的城镇，也许更大的城市。
They come here to change our culture. That's how the Beckers see it. Not to state the very, very obvious, but this is the opposite of Amy. Whereas she imagines their lives and needs, to the point of anguish sometimes, he doesn't believe they actually exist. He can't imagine their lives.
他们来到这里是为了改变我们的文化。这就是贝克一家看待它的方式。不是为了陈述非常、非常显而易见的事情，但这与艾米相反。鉴于她想象他们的生活和需要，有时甚至达到痛苦的地步，他不相信他们确实存在。他无法想象他们的生活。
Garden City has train tracks, and grain silos, and enormous wind turbines. It has cows in a field under a big metal sign that says Eat More Beef. It smells of shit around 4:00 in the afternoon. You can smell it at the Walmart parking lot.
加登城有火车轨道、粮仓和巨大的风力涡轮机。它在写着“多吃牛肉”的大金属标志下的田野里有奶牛。下午4点左右闻起来有屎味。你在沃尔玛停车场都能闻到。
But whatever politics that evokes for you, I believe most of the city doesn't agree with the Beckers. Of the people in town I found who wanted the office to close-- six-- 2/3 of them were Beckers. Their relative had been killed on a motorcycle by a Somali.
但无论那唤起你什么政治，我相信大多数城市不同意贝克一家。在我发现的人中想要办公室关闭——六个人——2/3是贝克一家。他们的亲戚被一个索马里人骑摩托车撞死了。
The county that Garden City is in is not majority white anymore. There are taco spots everywhere. There's a Vietnamese grocery store. There's a Somali neighborhood. And the IRC office, in a way, acts as the glue between these two parts of town that are coming together.
加登城所在的县不再是白人多数了。到处都是炸玉米饼摊。有一家越南杂货店。有一个索马里社区。而IRC办公室，在某种程度上，充当了城镇这两个正在汇合的部分之间的粘合剂。
My impression is that most people in town don't want the office to close at all. People like the chief of police, who loves Amy, loves the IRC office. They worked together particularly closely when the Somali community here was threatened by a bomb plot by white militia guys outside of town. The local hospital works closely with the IRC. So do the local schools.
我的印象是，镇上的大多数人根本不想办公室关闭。警察局长之类的人，他爱艾米，爱IRC办公室。当这里的索马里社区受到镇外白人民兵炸弹阴谋威胁时，他们工作得特别密切。当地医院与IRC合作密切。当地学校也是如此。
The Beckers complain newcomers aren't assimilating fast enough. John Becker said a few times, why don't they want to be Americans? But they very obviously do. That's why lots of them are in the IRC office day after day, like wide-eyed kids on the first day of high school. Help me figure out how to fit in. And that's what the IRC office helps them do.
贝克一家抱怨新来者没有足够快地同化。约翰·贝克说了好几次，为什么他们不想成为美国人？但他们显然非常想。这就是为什么他们中的很多人日复一日地在IRC办公室，像高中第一天睁大眼睛的孩子。帮我搞清楚如何融入。而那正是IRC办公室帮他们做的。
Close the back of the truck.
关上卡车后部。
The moving company has just finished packing up the truck and slams the back door shut. They're driving all the files to Wichita, where the lone IRC office in the state remains. We watch them drive away, cart off the whole office that she founded four years ago.
搬家公司刚刚装好卡车并砰地一声关上了后门。他们正开车把所有档案运往威奇托，那里是该州剩下的唯一IRC办公室。我们看着他们开车离开，运走她四年前创立的整个办公室。
All right. That is done. 3 o'clock, July 30.
好的。那是做完了。7月30日下午3点。
You did it.
你做到了。
Yeah.
是的。
There goes the office around the corner.
办公室转过拐角去了。
There goes the office around the corner. What next?
办公室转过拐角去了。接下来什么？
You know that feeling when you've packed everything up and you're like, whew, I did it. This was not that feeling.
你知道当你打包好一切时的那种感觉，你会像，呼，我做到了。这不是那种感觉。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话响了]
There is one thing, though, that Amy is really, truly satisfied about. You can hear it in her voice a few weeks later, a few weeks after the office is closed, when I call her.
不过，有一件事艾米确实感到真正满足。你可以在几周后，办公室关闭几周后，当我打电话给她时，从她的声音里听到它。
Hi, Zoe!
嗨，佐伊！
Hi, Amy.
嗨，艾米。
You want to say hi to Norkamal?
你想和诺卡马尔打个招呼吗？
Yes, I want to say hi to Norkamal.
是的，我想和诺卡马尔打个招呼。
Norkamal. He's the guy who whispered "Wednesday."
诺卡马尔。他就是那个耳语说“周三”的家伙。
Hello?
喂？
Hi!
嗨！
Hi. How are you?
嗨。你好吗？
Oh, my gosh! Oh, my gosh.
哦，天哪！哦，天哪。
I can talk.
我可以说话了。
You can talk! Your voice is so, like, loud and clear.
你可以说话了！你的声音听起来，比如，响亮而清晰。
Yeah. My voice is clear.
是的。我的声音清晰了。
And he has all this stuff to say. Amy says when she hears his voice, it sounds like one of her babies crying after he was just born.
他有很多话要说。艾米说当她听到他的声音时，听起来就像她刚出生的孩子之一在哭。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
This is the first time I have heard her, just, pure joy.
这是我第一次听到她，那种，纯粹的快乐。
[AMY LAUGHS AND SIGHS]
[艾米笑了并叹了口气]
Her office is closed, but she got this done.
她的办公室关闭了，但她完成了这个。
Zoe Chace. So podcast listeners, Zoe actually reported out an entire second story for today's program that we did not have time for on the radio, but she found some really interesting stuff. And since this podcast can be any length at all, I'm excited to play it for you now. This is a fifth act of today's show.
佐伊·切斯。所以播客听众们，佐伊实际上为今天的节目报道了整个第二个故事，我们广播时间不够，但她发现了一些非常有趣的东西。而且既然这个播客可以是任何长度，我很高兴为你播放它。这是今天节目的第五幕。
Don't tell anybody who heard the radio version of the show about this, OK? They don't need to know. It's just between us. Don't let them know how much better the podcast is.
别告诉任何听到节目广播版本的人关于这个，好吗？他们不需要知道。这只在我们之间。别让他们知道播客有多好。
This is Act Five of today's show. Act Five, Why So Few? And the best way to explain this story-- when Zoe was at the IRC office in Garden City, one of the refugees-- the guy at the beginning of her story, Edie-- he asked her at some point, like, why is this happening? Why are so few refugees coming in that this office has to close?
这是今天节目的第五幕。第五幕，为什么这么少？解释这个故事的最好方式——当佐伊在加登城的IRC办公室时，难民之一——她故事开头的那个家伙，伊迪——他在某一点问她，比如，这为什么会发生？为什么到来的难民这么少，以至于办公室不得不关闭？
And at the time, Zoe actually didn't really understand why. Like, why were only 22,000 refugees arriving in the United States if 45,000 was the number that the administration set for itself? And she looked into this, trying to figure it out. And to understand the answer, you have to go back to this promise that the President made back when he was a candidate. You remember this one.
当时，佐伊实际上真的不明白为什么。比如，如果45,000是政府为自己设定的数字，为什么只有2.2万难民到达美国？她对此进行了调查，试图弄清楚。为了理解答案，你必须回到总统还是候选人时做出的承诺。你记得这个。
Donald J. Trump is calling for a total and complete shutdown of Muslims entering the United States until our country's representatives can figure out what the hell is going on.
唐纳德·J·特朗普呼吁全面、彻底地关闭穆斯林进入美国，直到我们国家的代表搞清楚到底发生了什么。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼]
So the President acted on this campaign promise in his very first week in office with the travel ban, right? He banned travel to the United States from seven countries. But that was not all it did. It also shut down the refugee program. Like, the refugee program from all countries all over the world. It was, like, a total and complete shut down for 120 days.
所以总统在他上任的第一周就用旅行禁令兑现了这个竞选承诺，对吧？他禁止了七个国家的公民旅行到美国。但那不是它做的全部。它还关闭了难民计划。比如，来自世界各地所有国家的难民计划。这是一个为期120天的“全面、彻底的关闭”。
The idea is shut it down for 120 days while the administration figured out what the hell was going on. In other words, how we vet refugees that we resettle in this country. And at the end of 120 days, theoretically, the refugee resettlement program was supposed to start back up again.
想法是关闭它120天，同时政府搞清楚到底发生了什么。换句话说，我们如何审查我们在该国重新安置的难民。而在120天结束时，从理论上讲，难民安置计划应该重新开始。
But then something weird happened. Refugee resettlement, it never really started back up again. Not full force. Look at the numbers. Take Iraq, which is not on the President's travel ban list-- the final one. Last year, we let in 6,886 refugees. This year, 130.
但然后发生了一些奇怪的事情。难民安置，它从来没有真正重新开始。不是全力以赴。看看数字。以伊拉克为例，它不在总统的旅行禁令名单——最后一个名单上。去年，我们让6,886名难民进入。今年，130名。
OK. How come? Like, what happened? They went through a process, they came to a conclusion, they fixed their thing. Should have start started back up. What happened? Zoe searched around and found somebody who actually knows.
好的。为什么？比如，发生了什么？他们经历了一个过程，他们得出了一个结论，他们修复了他们的东西。应该重新开始。发生了什么？佐伊四处搜寻，找到了一个真正知道的人。
Back when Donald J. Trump said he wanted to know what the hell was going on, what he meant was, what's the vetting process for how we figure out who gets to come in? He didn't trust what was already in place. So when he announced the travel ban, the White House pulled together people from across the agencies. Homeland Security, the State Department, National Counterterrorism, Intelligence. All the people you'd want in a room like that.
当唐纳德·J·特朗普说他想知道到底发生了什么时，他指的是，我们如何搞清楚谁可以进来的审查过程是什么？他不信任已经到位的流程。所以当他宣布旅行禁令时，白宫从各个机构召集了人。国土安全部、国务院、国家反恐、情报。所有你想要在那个房间里的所有你想要的人。
And one of the people in the room was Barbara Strack. She was the chief of refugee admissions for USCIS, USCIS being a Department of Homeland Security that handles immigration. She remembers their first meeting on day one of 120.
房间里的人之一是芭芭拉·斯特拉克。她是USCIS（处理移民的国土安全部的一个部门）难民准入部门的负责人。她记得他们120天的第一天的第一次会议。
We met in a large conference room that was really full with people around the table and people against the wall. And--
我们在一个巨大的会议室见面，里面真的挤满了桌子周围的人和墙边的人。而且——
It was a lot of people.
人很多。
A lot of people.
很多人。
Barbara says the way most people in the room were looking at it was like this. The refugee program is already incredibly rigorous. It's months, sometimes years, of interviews, data collection, security checks.
芭芭拉说大多数房间里的人是这样看的。难民计划已经极其严格。这是数月，有时数年的面试、数据收集、安全检查。
The people in the room were, like, we think of this as very safe. But OK, let's do better. Let's make what we already think is extreme vetting more extreme. It was a real A team. The top people. Barbara says everyone was on the same page.
房间里的人，就像，我们认为这是非常安全的。但好的，让我们做得更好。让我们把你已经认为的“极端审查”变得更极端。这是一个真正的A团队。顶尖的人。芭芭拉说每个人都在同一页上。
Our goal is that this program is up and running again on day 121. So we need to be very organized. We need to meet quickly and get the program through the other side when there can be confidence again.
我们的目标是这个计划在第121天重新启动。所以我们需要非常有组织。我们需要快速会面并让该计划通过另一边，那时才能再次有信心。
I talked to three other officials who are involved in the 120-day group, two who still work in government, and they all felt like Barbara. Let's put our back into it, focus, hit the target. So they do it. They meet, they divide into subgroups, they write up a report that makes a bunch of recommendations, which are classified.
我和另外三名参与120天小组的官员交谈过，其中两名现在还在政府工作，他们都感觉像芭芭拉。让我们投入努力，聚焦，击中目标。所以他们做了。他们会面，他们分成小组，他们写了一份报告，提出了一系列建议，这些建议是机密的。
My impression from Barbara and the others who worked on this was we implemented every improvement we could imagine to a process that was already tight. And the final conclusion of this group of experts was if you institute these improvements into the process that we already have, for sure, it is safe to turn the program back on. So go ahead. Start admitting the refugees again with the more extreme vetting that you wanted.
我对芭芭拉和其他做这件事的人的印象是我们对一个本来就已经很紧密的流程实施了我们能想象到的每一个改进。而这个专家小组的最终结论是如果你将这些改进引入我们已经拥有的流程中，可以肯定的是，重新启动该计划是安全的。所以继续吧。用你想要的更极端的审查再次开始接纳难民。
And then, on about 110 of the 120 days, they hear back from the White House. The White House did not like the conclusion of this review. And according to Barbara and the others I spoke to in the group, the White House wanted it to change.
然后，在大约120天的第110天，他们收到了白宫的回应。白宫不喜欢这次审查的结论。而且据芭芭拉和我在小组中交谈过的其他人说，白宫希望它改变。
They had expressed concern about the recommendation to resume refugee processing of all nationalities.
他们对恢复所有国籍的难民处理的建议表示担忧。
And do you know which nationalities the White House was worried about?
而且你知道白宫担心哪些国籍吗？
I'm trying to think if there's any reason not to say this on the record. There's probably not. I was told that there was particular concern about Somali nationals.
我正在尝试想是否有什么理由不在记录上说这个。可能没有。我被告知对索马里国民有特别的担忧。
The administration specifically pointed to Somalis as the sticking point.
政府特别指出索马里人是症结所在。
Why?
为什么？
I don't know.
我不知道。
What do you think?
你认为呢？
I honestly can't speculate.
我诚实地不能推测。
You don't want to speculate.
你不想推测。
No, I honestly-- to this day, I don't know.
不，我诚实地——直到今天，我都不知道。
And there's no rationale that you were given? Like, because Somalia is like this or like that.
而且没有给你任何理由？比如，因为索马里是这样的或者那样的。
The rationale wasn't shared with me.
理由没有分享给我。
Two government officials confirmed this for me. Somalia wasn't the only concern, they said, but it was a major concern. It was chief of staff John Kelly, in particular, who was unhappy, they said. I think it was bullshit, one guy in the group told me. At the end of the day, the data didn't show that Somalis were any special risk.
两名政府官员向我证实了这一点。索马里不是唯一的担忧，他们说，但它是一个主要担忧。他们说，特别是幕僚长约翰·凯利，他不高兴。小组里的一个人告诉我，我认为那是胡扯。归根结底，数据没有显示索马里人有任何特殊的风险。
So after 120 days, the White House reopened the refugee program for some countries, but not for a handful of countries who make up a lot of the refugees that are resettled here. For Somalia and 10 others, including all the countries in the original travel ban, the refugee program would stay suspended. For them, the 120 day review got another 90 days.
所以120天后，白宫为一些国家重新开放了难民计划，但没有为少数在这里重新安置的难民中的很多国家开放。对于索马里和其他10个国家，包括原旅行禁令中的所有国家，难民计划将保持暂停。对他们来说，120天的审查又多了90天。
My boss asked me to think about options for how to address the White House's concerns.
我的老板让我考虑如何解决白宫担忧的方案。
Barbara says she and the other members of her group were sort of at a loss for what else they could possibly review. But they went back to work. They came up with some more recommendations. After 90 days, in January 2018, the White House did restart the whole refugee program. But it was like turning on a faucet and nothing coming out.
芭芭拉说她和她小组的其他成员对于他们还能审查什么感到有些迷茫。但他们回到工作岗位。他们想出了一些更多的建议。90天后，即2018年1月，白宫确实重启了整个难民计划。但它就像打开水龙头，却什么也没流出来。
If you look at Somalia and those 10 other countries, this fiscal year it looks like we will admit 3% of who we allowed just the year before. Last year, we admitted more than 6,000 Somalis. This year, just 250. The extreme vetting has gotten so extreme, it seems, that few people can actually get through it.
如果你看看索马里和那其他10个国家，这个财年看起来我们将接纳我们仅在上一年允许的人数的3%。去年，我们接纳了超过6000名索马里人。今年，只有250名。看来极端审查已经变得如此极端，以至于很少有人真正能通过。
Barbara says the changes they recommended shouldn't have had this effect. It shouldn't have slowed things down so much. Others I spoke to from the group said the same thing. It's not clear why the numbers are so low, but Barbara and the other people I talked to said the White House just never supplied the staffing and the resources to carry out the new vetting.
芭芭拉说他们建议的更改不应该有这种效果。它不应该让事情慢这么多。我从小组中交谈过的其他人说了同样的事情。目前还不清楚为什么数字这么低，但芭芭拉和我交谈过的其他人说，白宫只是从来没有提供人员和资源来执行新的审查。
A few people told me that the FBI, in particular, isn't staffed up enough to do the checks it's supposed to do. As a result, there's not a ban in place on these refugees, but the outcome is nearly the same.
几个人告诉我，特别是联邦调查局，没有足够的人员来做它应该做的检查。结果，这些难民没有禁令到位，但结果几乎是一样的。
A DHS spokesperson said the new screening procedures are undoubtedly making America safer. They point to one specific example. An Iraqi wanted for murder in Iraq who entered the United States through our refugee program in 2014. They said today, with the new vetting procedures, he would not have made it through.
国土安全部发言人表示，新的筛选程序无疑使美国更安全。他们指出了一个具体的例子。一名在伊拉克因谋杀被通缉的伊拉克人，他在2014年通过我们的难民计划进入了美国。他们说今天，有了新的审查程序，他就不会通过了。
There is some risk with every immigration program. If you wanted a zero-risk immigration system, you wouldn't have any immigration at all.
每一个移民计划都有一些风险。如果你想要一个零风险的移民系统，你根本就不会有任何移民。
My sense is that the risk tolerance of this administration is very, very low with regard to the refugee program. You know, approaching zero.
我的感觉是，这个政府在难民计划方面的风险承受能力非常、非常低。你知道，接近零。
Barbara thinks, though I believe DHS would deny this, that they just want a different kind of refugee coming in, if any come in at all. She and another staffer told me about various times going up to the Hill to talk about the refugee program to Congress back when Jeff Sessions was a senator.
芭芭拉认为，虽然我相信国土安全部会否认这一点，但他们只是想要不同类型的难民进来，如果有任何难民进来。她和另一名工作人员告诉我，回到杰夫·塞申斯担任参议员时，他们多次去国会谈论难民计划。
Do you vet for culture? he asked. Another time she saw someone else who's now a Trump official, Gene Hamilton, for a briefing. Do you screen for integration potential, Hamilton asked, the ability to assimilate? No, she said.
你审查文化吗？他问。另一次她看到了现在是特朗普官员的人，吉恩·汉密尔顿，进行简报。你审查整合潜力吗，汉密尔顿问，融入的能力？不，她说。
That's something we've always taken pride in, actually, as a country, she told him. The standard for refugee resettlement has always been vulnerability. How much can we do for you, not how much you can do for us.
她告诉他，这实际上是我们一直引以为傲的国家标准。难民安置的标准一直是脆弱性。我们能为你做多少，而不是你能为我们做多少。
Zoe Chace. Again, remember, this story is our secret. Don't tell anybody who heard the radio show. OK.
佐伊·切斯。再说一次，记住，这个故事是我们的秘密。别告诉任何听到广播节目的人。好的。
[MUSIC - PUSSY RIOT, "MAKE AMERICAN GREAT AGAIN"]
[音乐 - 暴动小猫 (Pussy Riot), "Make American Great Again"]
What do you want your world to look like? What do you want it to be? Do you know that a wall has two sides and nobody is free? Did your mama come from Mexico? Papa come from Palestine? Sneaking all through Syria, crossing all the border lines.
你想要你的世界看起来是什么样子？你想要它是什么？你知道一堵墙有两边而且没有人是自由的吗？你的妈妈来自墨西哥吗？爸爸来自巴勒斯坦吗？偷偷摸摸穿过叙利亚，越过所有的边界线。
Our program was produced today by Nadia Reiman. People who put together today's show included Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Neil Drumming, Hillary Elkins, Damian Grave, Michelle Harris, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Anna Martin, Miki Meek, Ben Phelan, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由纳迪亚·雷曼制作。把今天节目放在一起的人包括佐伊·切斯、达娜·齐维斯、尼尔·德拉明、希拉里·埃尔金斯、达米安·格雷夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·克斯滕鲍姆、塞斯·林德、安娜·马丁、米基·米克、本·费伦、罗宾·塞米恩、阿利萨·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our Senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton. Special thanks today to so many lawyers. Erica [INAUDIBLE], Nicole Ramos, [INAUDIBLE], Bob [INAUDIBLE], Jennifer Walker Gates, Miriam Ackerman, Morgan [INAUDIBLE], Ana Maria Schwartz, Anastasia Tonello, Edna Yang, Steven [? Navar, ?] Rebecca [INAUDIBLE], Francisco [INAUDIBLE], Crystal [INAUDIBLE], Sandra Feist, Emmy McLean, Teigen [INAUDIBLE], Andy [INAUDIBLE], Rebecca Brown, Rebecca Press, and many others at Central American Legal Assistance.
我们的高级制片人是布莱恩·里德。我们的执行主编是苏珊·伯顿。今天特别感谢这么多律师。埃里卡 [听不清]、妮可·拉莫斯、[听不清]、鲍勃 [听不清]、詹妮弗·沃克·盖茨、米里亚姆·阿克曼、摩根 [听不清]、安娜·玛丽亚·施瓦茨、阿纳斯塔西娅·托内洛、埃德娜·杨、史蒂文 [? 纳瓦尔, ?] 丽贝卡 [听不清]、弗朗西斯科 [听不清]、克里斯托· [听不清]、桑德拉·法斯特、艾米·麦克莱恩、泰根 [听不清]、安迪 [听不清]、丽贝卡·布朗、丽贝卡·普雷斯，以及中美洲法律援助处的许多其他人。
Also [INAUDIBLE], Robbie Grammer, Ben Kestling, Mark O'Brien, Marcy Smith, Katie [INAUDIBLE], Eric Schwartz, Sarah [? Kraus, ?] Jennifer [? Sine, ?] Mary [? Giovanolli. ?] And a bunch of government spokespeople, including [INAUDIBLE], Michael [? Bars, ?] and [? Devin ?] [? O'Malley. ?]
还有 [听不清]、罗比·格拉默、本·凯斯特林、马克·奥布莱恩、马西·史密斯、凯蒂 [听不清]、埃里克·施瓦茨、萨拉 [? 克劳斯, ?] 詹妮弗 [? 西恩, ?] 玛丽 [? 乔瓦诺利. ?] 以及一群政府发言人，包括 [听不清]、迈克尔 [? 巴斯, ?] 和 [? 德文 ?] [? 奥马利. ?]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he keeps inviting me to this little vacation house he has. And whenever I ask him, like, what is it like? He's so vague. He's just--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。这是美国生活通过PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他一直邀请我去他拥有的这个小度假屋。每当我问他，比如，它是什么样的？他那么模糊。他只是——
The country conditions are what they are.
国家条件就是那样。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - PUSSY RIOT, "MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN"]
[音乐 - 暴动小猫 (Pussy Riot), "Make America Great Again"]
Make America great again.
让美国再次伟大。